Andrew Huberman: Welcome to the
Huberman Lab Guest series, where I and
an expert guest discuss science and
science based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman, and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today marks the fourth episode in
our four episode series with Dr.
Paul Conti about mental health.
Today's episode deals with
the topic of self care.
We hear the phrase self care a
lot nowadays, but rarely, if ever,
is self care precisely defined.
For instance, is self care
about pampering oneself?
Is it about self acceptance?
Is self care about just making sure we
get enough sleep and enough exercise
and have healthy relationships?
Well, it turns out that yes,
indeed, adequate self care
is about all of those things.
But true self care, the topic of
today's episode, is about far more
as it relates to our mental health.
True self care is also about constructing
a life narrative in which we frame
our past, our present and future in
a way that allows us to see what's
gone wrong, what's gone right, and
the best path to navigate forward.
So in many ways, true self care is
really about fostering a sense of self
awareness, and doing so within the context
of a framework that is known to work.
And today, Dr.
Paul Conti shares with us
exactly how to do that.
He also touches on some of the things
that, if not properly understood and
processed, can inhibit our ability to take
excellent care of ourselves, including
how to properly process traumatic
experiences, something that he is expert
in, among many other topics as well.
He also touches on some of the things
that can potentially serve as barriers
to excellent self care, including
traumatic experiences, and explains how
to frame those traumatic experiences
so that we can best move forward.
He also shares with us various
practices that include therapy, but
also practices that we can carry out
on our own, such as specific forms of
meditation, journaling, and other ways of
examining the self and fostering better
self care toward our mental health.
As I mentioned before, this is the
fourth episode in our four episode
series all about mental health.
I realize that perhaps not everyone has
had the opportunity yet to listen to the
previous three episodes in this series.
If you haven't, it certainly won't prevent
you from gleaning important information
and protocols from today's episode.
But I do encourage you at some
point to try and listen to all four
episodes in this series because at
some level they are interwoven at the
level of concepts and of practices.
I'd also like to highlight that Dr.
Paul Conti has generously provided
some simple diagrams that can help
you navigate today's material and
the material in the other episodes.
They are available as zero cost PDFs by
simply going to the show note captions
where you can view them or download them.
Before we begin, I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public.
I n keeping with that theme, I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is BetterHelp.
BetterHelp offers professional
therapy with a licensed
therapist carried out all online.
I've been doing therapy
for more than 30 years.
While I confess that initially I was
forced to do that therapy as a condition
for being let back into high school,
over time I learned that therapy is
a tremendously valuable practice.
In fact, I consider doing regular
weekly therapy as just as important
as doing regular physical exercise
in order to improve one's health.
The beauty of BetterHelp is that it
makes it extremely easy to find a
therapist that's excellent for you.
And we can define an excellent
therapist as somebody who's going to
give you a lot of support, but in an
objective way, as well as somebody
with whom you can have excellent
rapport and that can help you arrive
at positively transformative insights
that you wouldn't have otherwise had.
And with BetterHelp, they make
it convenient so that it's
matched to your schedule and
the other aspects of your life.
If you'd like to try BetterHelp,
go to betterhelp.com/huberman
to get 10% off your first month.
Again, that's betterhelp.com/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Waking up.
Waking up is a meditation app that
offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions, mindfulness trainings,
Yoga Nidra sessions, and more.
By now, there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily meditations
can greatly improve our mood, reduce
anxiety, improve our ability to
focus, and can improve our memory.
And while there are many different
forms of meditation, most people
find it difficult to find and stick
to a meditation practice in a way
that is most beneficial for them.
The Waking up app makes it extremely
easy to learn how to meditate and
to carry out your daily meditation
practice in a way that's going to be
most effective and efficient for you.
It includes a variety of different types
of meditations of different duration,
as well as things like Yoga Nidra, which
place the brain and body into a sort of
pseudosleep that allows you to emerge
feeling incredibly mentally refreshed.
In fact, the science around Yoga Nidra is
really impressive, showing that after a
yoga Nidra session, levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60%, which places the brain and
body into a state of enhanced readiness
for mental work and for physical work.
Another thing I really like about
the Waking up app is that it provides
a 30 day introduction course.
So for those of you that have n ot
meditated before or getting back to a
meditation practice, that's fantastic.
Or if you're somebody who's already a
skilled and regular meditator, waking
up has more advanced meditations and
Yoga Nidra sessions for you as well.
If you'd like to try the waking up app,
you can go to wakingup.com/huberman
and access a free 30 day trial.
Again, that's wakingup.com/huberman
.
And now for my discussion
about mental health with Dr.
Paul Conti.
Dr.
Conti, welcome back.
Paul Conti: Thank you.
Pleasure to be here.
Andrew Huberman: For this series, we've
been focusing on mental health and
really defining what mental health is
and a roadmap to achieve mental health.
And in episode one, you laid out for us
a map, essentially, of the things that
any and all of us can look at pretty much
at any time, with essentially any degree
of resources to try and get a better
understanding of ourselves and how well or
not well we happen to be moving toward or
creating true mental health for ourselves.
In addition to that, you spelled out for
us what true mental health really is.
And just to recap a little bit of that,
it really boils down to these verb states,
action states of agency and gratitude.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: And then in episode
two, you covered some of the common
challenges that you've observed in
life and in your clinical practice.
And we address some of the ways that
people can overcome those challenges by
going to the map, opening the so called
cupboards as we're referring to them,
and asking specific sorts of questions.
And then in episode three, we talked about
how looking at the map and exploring the
map in those cupboards in particular can
help people in relational aspects of life.
Romantic relationship, work
relationships, family relationships,
and the relationship to self.
Paul Conti: Yes, very important.
Andrew Huberman: Very important.
Paul Conti: The foundation of all
relationships outside of ourselves.
Andrew Huberman: And I'm so glad that
you highlighted the relationship to
self, because today's episode, we
will, of course, return to the map.
And I should mention that if
people have not seen episodes
one, two, or three, that's okay.
Today's discussion will be
entirely accessible to them.
But I do recommend that at some point,
they especially listen to episode one and
hopefully episodes two and three as well.
But today's discussion is really about
the aspects of ourselves that exist in
all people and the action steps, the
paths of inquiry that are available
to all people that can allow anyone
and everyone to improve their mental
health, to move toward these ideals of
agency and gratitude on a regular basis.
And as you pointed out, it is a process.
It's not that we arrive
at agency and gratitude.
And just to reiterate, agency
and gratitude are verb states.
They involve ways of being in the world.
Paul Conti: They're active processes.
Like life is an active process.
There's not an endpoint
we're trying to reach.
We're trying to live.
Andrew Huberman: And in thinking
about today's discussion, it occurred
to both of us, really, that today's
discussion is really about self care.
Self care as a concept, I think, for
many people, evokes notions of like,
okay, you're going to take a vacation
or you're going to kick your feet up
or get a massage, things of that sort.
And certainly it can involve
those sorts of things.
But just as if we were having a discussion
about physical health and we were
going to talk about ways to take care
of the physical body to enhance health
span and lifespan, today's discussion
is really about how to take care of
the internal landscape, the mind.
Paul Conti: Right.
Andrew Huberman: Which also
qualifies very strongly as self care.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: So if you would, could
you tell us how you think about self
care, regardless of whether or not you
have a patient who's dealing with severe
mental illness or somebody who's just
hitting the same speed bumps of life over
and over again or anything in between.
What sorts of self care practices
and mindsets do you suggest
people take on for themselves?
And for that matter, how do
you think about self care?
Paul Conti: Well, I think we start with
factors that are really just baseline
factors that have to be in place in
order to achieve good things upon them.
So the basics of we have to be
eating well enough to feel okay
and hopefully eating really well.
We have to stay hydrated, we have to
get sleep, we have to move the body.
These are basics, but basics a lot
of people are not attending to.
Similarly, we have to be in
a situation that isn't making
fear and misery all the time.
So an example of an abusive relationship.
A person has to navigate out
of that before they can really
start taking care of themselves
in the way that builds goodness.
So we look for the basic factors
that we need to take care of in order
to then look at the factors that
become particular to each of us.
And what we're really looking
for is self understanding.
How much can we understand
about ourselves?
Be knowledgeable about what's going
on inside of us, why it's going on.
Also, and very importantly, being
aware that we don't know everything
that goes on inside of us, and being
curious about that and looking at how
we're engaging with the world around us.
Do we feel happy?
Do we not feel happy?
How do we define what happy means?
How are we engaging with the world?
Because, as you were saying, the
agency and gratitude are verb states.
So how are we living life?
How are we engaging with the world?
Do we feel like life is a sequence
of things I have to do, for
example, or are we doing things we
really, really don't want to do?
Do we have to do those things?
How could life be different?
We start looking at ourselves to assess
how we're engaging with ourselves, the
people, the world around us, in a way that
is either generative or not generative.
If we're in that state of agency
and gratitude, then we are going
to have periods of time where we
feel peaceful, we feel a sense of
contentment, or we feel delighted.
So is any of that in my life?
If not, why can I start
thinking about that?
Sometimes the answer is quite clear, like,
oh, there's this thing I love, and I'm
not doing that, right, and I can't do it.
And then you revisit, like, is
it true that you can't do it?
A lot of times it is not true.
And if it is true, how does the
person come to terms with that
process that perhaps grieve?
So say, if it's a loss of a person
that can keep people in terrible
misery over years and years.
So there may be things we have to
understand, we have to process so that we
can get ourselves to that place of knowing
ourselves pretty well and engaging in the
world in ways that we have a pretty good
understanding of and that are adaptive.
And then we look to say, okay,
now how do I make that better?
Because now we're thinking
about preventive medicine.
We want our bodies to be healthy because,
of course, we want to be healthy today.
But we also don't know what will
happen in the future Will there
be an injury or an illness?
I mean, eventually we all have an injury
or an illness in some way or another.
So we're preparing for the
predictable challenges that
will come our way in the future.
And we're well served by doing this
about our mental health, too, right?
There will be challenges that
come our way, there will be losses
and stressors and things that
make us feel bad or feel scared.
These things will happen to us.
So the healthier we are, the better today
is, and the better we set ourselves up to.
Either make tomorrow even better today,
or if tomorrow gives me a challenge
I don't have today, I can meet that
challenge and get back to a better place.
Andrew Huberman: So if I understand
correctly, it sounds like one of the
cornerstones of self care for sake
of mental health involves asking
really good questions about oneself.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: I don't think I've
ever heard it defined that way before.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: It's in such stark
contrast to the other forms of self
care, which I certainly subscribe to
as well, like making sure one gets
enough rest and avoids toxic people
to the extent one can, et cetera,
or toxic environments and so on.
Paul Conti: Right.
You mentioned ask questions of the self.
But the logical next question to that
is, well, what questions do I ask myself?
Sometimes we know we have
an idea, sometimes we don't.
And this is where the construction
of a life narrative, like,
let me think about my life.
Let me potentially talk about my
life with a trusted other person.
Let me potentially write down
a narrative about my life.
And we can learn so much from doing that.
So the person who thinks back and
starts to tell a story of themselves,
and let's say, just as an example, that
story is going pretty well, and the
person is feeling pretty good about
themselves, and then say something
happens and it starts to change.
Or then this thing happened, and
then I started kind of spending
time with different people, or I
started dating different people,
or I took a different kind of job.
And it can engender the reflection
of, like, oh, things really kind of
changed then, because the emotion
systems within us don't care
about the clock or the calendar.
The emotions, often of negative
experiences, can backmap into our lives.
And someone who can tell you, I was
miserable ever since I was a child
can then write out a life narrative
that describes a very happy childhood
until something happened or something
changed at a certain point, which
could be something dramatic, or it
might be increasing pressures of
school, or increasing social pressures,
or how things changed at puberty.
And if we have an understanding of
that, we may know the right questions.
Like, for example, let's say
afterwards the person finds
that they're drinking more.
An example, but a common example,
instead of taking that for granted.
Oh, that's what I do.
Or, yeah, I can't cope any better, right?
The negative things people
will say to themselves.
The narrative can often
point out, I can cope better.
I did cope better.
I did feel differently about myself.
So the life narrative can really
help us establish the roadmap.
And part of what the life
narrative does is it guides us to
the places to ask the questions.
Andrew Huberman: If you would be so kind
as to tell us a little bit more about
how one would do this on their own.
So does this involve
journaling things out?
I confess I have a file on my computer
that has a bunch of other files that
starts with age zero to five, and
then I have some notes in there.
It's not an autobiography, far from it.
It's just highlights of events
that I remember, six to ten
and so on and places I lived.
And I use it just to kind
of orient myself in time.
I actually don't know what the purpose
and utility of it is, why I initially
started doing this, but it's an important
file to me, and when I return to it, I
often remember additional key events.
So it's constantly growing.
I mean, these files are getting
quite large, again, with no specific
purpose of writing this out at
any point, but just to orient.
Paul Conti: Right.
You can't not learn about
yourself from doing that.
It exposes truths of self.
It makes you ponder about things.
It draws your attention to ways in
which you've changed, whether you
think those ways are good or bad.
It draws your attention to change.
It draws your attention to
the impact of external events.
And as you said, it grounds you.
It provides a way of
localizing oneself in time.
Like, I am here now.
Wait, how did I get here?
And the thoughts and ideas of
how we got here very much help us
because often we don't do that.
We're sort of rushing headlong
forward, because in many ways,
our society is prompting us.
We live in a very fast moving society and
we want information and gratification,
and often we don't even want it very fast,
but it's coming at us very fast anyway.
And to stop and reflect makes a very,
very big difference even to think
at times beyond our generations.
To the best of my knowledge, the vast
majority of people on one side of my
family, everyone was a shepherd for every
generation until, like, two ago, right?
And thinking about that of,
like, that's interesting.
It makes me, in many ways, grateful.
So grateful for the opportunity I've had.
But I also think, well, they
lived in close knit communities
then, and what was that like?
And we begin to see ourselves in a broader
way, both in our own history and then
projecting forward, which sometimes is
about children and nurturing children.
But it can certainly
be about other things.
It can be about friendship.
It can be about work.
So we start to see ourselves in ways
that are interesting, that are through
the lens of truth, and that speak
to our place in the world around us.
And I think this engenders
both agency and gratitude.
If I'm aware of, like, what have I done?
What have I accomplished?
When haven't I accomplished things?
How might that be different?
And a sense of gratitude for being
here and having opportunity and
even be able to think about this.
My guess is when you read through
those files, that at some points,
you have sort of a sense of marvel,
while, like, whoa, that's me.
Right?
Whether it's a good memory
or it's a difficult memory.
No, it's all part of you that
leads you through to today.
And you do have a better
sense of self through that.
Andrew Huberman: One of the feelings
I most often come away from those
excursions into those files with is
one of gratitude, because so much of
what's in those files are recollections
of others that I really appreciate.
Some are still alive, some aren't.
And what that's meant to me and how that
carries me forward, so that's what I do.
I'm sure there are a near infinite
number of ways that people could
do this, but what are a few that
you've seen work really well
that people can do on their own?
Or perhaps with a clinician as well?
In fact, that raises the question,
should people share this sort of
practice and the contents of that
practice with a trusted clinician?
Paul Conti: I think sharing with another
person always should be a trusted other.
And we can kind of take stock of that, of
people have an idea of who may be safe.
Often people say, oh, there's no
one I could share something with.
But really, that often comes through a
lens of fear, of exposure, of self, of
rejection, of vulnerability, which often
is warranted, but sometimes is not.
Sometimes there really are.
In fact, often there are safe people.
So the act of doing something other
than just thinking about something
brings, as you well know, it brings
parts of our brain online that then
are thinking in a different way.
So, for example, they may bring
error correction mechanisms online.
So if I'm thinking over and over again
that I've never been good enough to do
anything, that can be just automatic
inside of me, but if I start to write
or to talk or even to formulate words,
to talk to myself or to put words in my
mind as if I were talking now, we come
at it in a different way, and we can sort
of ferret out the truth within us, which
might be, it's not true that I've never
been able to do things or achieve things.
And people often bring that
online by doing something other
than the same thought process
that's gone often over and over.
And it's nonproductive, and it brings
down mood, and it raises anxiety, and
it also builds a sense of futility.
I mean, I cannot tell you how
often I've heard a person say,
no good will come of this.
Or like, okay, try, we'll
try, but I know I can't be up.
I've been thinking about this for
ten years or 20 years, but what
they've been doing is the same thing.
They've been ruminating
on it for ten years.
They start talking about it and people
will say, oh my goodness, I've achieved
more in 2 hours than I did in years.
But that's because you're doing
something different in the 2 hours.
So I think that's very important,
especially because we can't say,
okay, go look in your unconscious
mind and see what you find there.
So then we need ways of
accessing the unconscious mind.
And the communication, either with
self, in writing with others, can
be very, very helpful in doing that.
I am a firm believer
that knowledge is power.
Many times I will feel like I have a
sense of really having helped someone,
and the other person may have that
sense, and we can see the change.
And all that I've done is
impart knowledge, right?
We all know different things.
So often it's the case that, hey, I happen
to have learned things that are different
from what that other person learns.
And then I'm communicating
to them things that I have
learned, so they know them too.
And then they feel tremendously better.
Because if we put inside of ourselves
the tools of understanding our
unconscious minds, and sometimes
our conscious minds too will work
on them, we'll make use of them.
If you talk to a person, for example,
about how trauma can impact us and
how we can shove it underneath the
surface and how it can spin off
shame, then that person may take that
knowledge away and come back with
real understanding and the fact that
we can do this on our own, right?
We can do this through good resources.
We can do this by taking information into
ourselves that can be very, very helpful.
And it doesn't require, because the first
place to start are with things we can
do that don't require professional help.
And sometimes we may come at
problems that do tell us that
we should get professional help.
So if we're having thoughts
of self harm, thoughts of not
wanting to be alive, thoughts of
real despair, thoughts of real.
Of hopelessness, that's telling
us, okay, let's get some help.
There's a role and a place for
professional help, but people come to
professional help in other ways, too.
Such as, for example, reflecting on
the self real example person thinking.
It really became kind of
different when things started
changing, like, after college.
And then I thought like, oh, I've kind
of gotten to this place and I've got a
good job and things really should get
better, but they kind of haven't, right?
And that was really a branch point.
That person may have never
really thought about that.
Or they may have thought about it 10,000
times and then shoved it underneath.
From consciousness to
unconsciousness, because it's a
scary, vulnerability inducing thing.
It seems scary.
Like, how could it be that I achieved
things and didn't get healthier?
Now we're afraid of that, right?
And letting that come to the surface,
being able to say, oh, that's true.
I don't have to be afraid
to shine light on that.
Then a lot of times that alone, sometimes
a person will solve their own problems.
They think about it.
They come in, they have all the answers.
They thank me.
I did nothing but listen.
But the listening part is important.
It allowed them to come in and
say what they needed to say.
And other times, then it can be that.
But it's not always that.
Other times it informs us about
what to work on clinically.
And it might not be
something that's dire, right?
It might just be like, I
want to understand this.
I want to be happier.
I want to be healthier.
I want to work towards these good things.
When people talk about that, they're
always, if you really distill
down, what are they talking about?
A sense of peace, a sense of
contentment coming at the world
through agency and gratitude.
And we can do that through self
inquiry, including through therapy.
It doesn't have to just be for
situations where, oh, there's
a significant clinical problem.
Andrew Huberman: Is it the case that
when somebody journals a bit of their
life narrative or thinks about some great
or sadly traumatic events that perhaps
happened to them at whatever stage of
life, that there is something accomplished
in that action or in that therapy session,
if they're doing it with a clinician, but
that when they go to sleep that night and
perhaps in their waking states as well,
that the unconscious is working some of
that through such, that revelations come
to mind, later insights come to mind.
I'm certainly familiar with the
fact that there are certain times
of day and evening where my brain
is in a bit of a liminal state.
It feels like somewhere
between sleep and awake.
And I just have learned that provided
I block against outside sensory input
as much as I can, in particular social
media and the news, that I'll just be
doing the dishes or preparing coffee
or something, and something will come
to mind seemingly out of nowhere.
It's not always a great insight.
In fact, it's rarely a great insight,
but it always takes me a bit by surprise.
Sometimes a little bit of delight,
sometimes a little bit of shock.
Like, wow, where did that come from?
Paul Conti: Because it came from
your unconscious mind, right?
It was invisible to you.
Then it got thrown up
and you're like, whoa.
And you realize it while in the midst
of doing something relatively mundane.
Because during the day you're engaging,
your brain is highly engaged, which is
great, but it doesn't leave a lot of
room for the unconscious mind to do its
millions and millions of things a second
that can help you figure things out,
which is the same reason it's uncanny.
Any psychiatrist will tell
you this, that a person will
come in and say, it's strange.
All of a sudden when I can finally
relax, that's when I have a panic attack.
Or they don't know.
Then I can finally relax and I go, then
my heart's beating fast and I'm sweating.
Because that's when
the panic attacks come.
If the person is laboring
under something that is causing
them this constant distress.
When you stop focusing outward and you
sort of settle into an inward state,
then the things that are underneath the
surface are going to come to the surface.
And if there's something really
bothering you that your brain is
very upset about or very afraid of,
what does it throw up to the surface?
A panic attack.
But if you're in a good place,
you're taking care of yourself,
you're in a generative stage,
you're in a safe environment.
Then when you stop putting all
the attention outward, so we
imagine then salience changes.
And instead of a lot of the salience
being outward, it starts to be inward.
And you're just sort of meditative.
You're washing the dishes.
And there's room then for
your unconscious mind to throw
something important to the surface.
It's the exact opposite of how
people can't remember something
if they're trying to think of it.
I mean, we all go through this
like, I can't remember that person's
name or that restaurant or whatever
it is, try to keep thinking about
it and see if you figure it out.
The answer is not in your conscious mind.
So if you keep bringing your
conscious mind to bear, you
just generate frustration.
But then when you stop thinking about
it, the answer is there inside of you.
Oh, I remember now.
So that's how if we have the
conscious mind engaged in something,
it's not going to figure out.
Then it doesn't figure the thing out.
And that works for our problems, too.
That's why a person can say, I
thought about that for ten years.
No, you ruminated about it for ten years.
It just ran over and over and
over in the conscious mind.
And how ironic, right?
It prevents understanding.
Andrew Huberman: So it's very clear to
me that asking certain kinds of questions
about oneself and one's self narrative
life history essentially can be very
beneficial in the moment or moments
of doing that practice as well as the
subconscious, or I guess the appropriate
way to refer to it, is the unconscious.
Right?
Okay.
So for those out there
who, like me, sometimes say
subconscious, it's unconscious.
The unconscious can throw things up to
the surface that can be real insights
can give us not just panic attacks, which
I think most people would like to shy
away from, but as you point out, there's
information in the fact that the panic
attack is occurring under conditions.
Paul Conti: And if you stir up the
pot of the unconscious and you put
some new information in, it can do new
things, it can figure new things out.
Which is why the process of
self-reflection, for example, and often
the process of therapy is not always, and
in fact, often is not a pleasant process.
But then we take away from that
hard work, renewed insights.
So someone, this happens all the time.
Who knows?
They know that a certain trauma
is inside of them and has been
affecting them, whether it's for
days or weeks or years, they know it.
They don't know what to do about it.
They have a conflict about it, so they
keep trying to shove it under the surface.
They finally accept, for whatever
reason, to talk about it.
What often happens then is, let's
say during three or four successive
weeks of hourly therapy, that
person is crying and that person
is upset or that person is angry.
I mean, it doesn't always happen this
way, but it does a fair amount of the
time as they get better and better.
Right, because they're
discharging some of the energy.
Maybe they're crying and they're
sad because they're grieving
something they haven't grieved
before because they've just been
angry or they've just been ashamed.
A classic example is a death.
I mean, how many times do people think,
well, that can't be still affecting me.
It was X number of years ago.
But they've never actually
grieved because they carry in
them, oh, it was my fault, right.
And how many times do we hear that I
should have said something different
before, I should have gone, we then
backmap something that makes us feel bad.
And then from the guilt and shame
comes the inability to process grief.
So if the person then deals with.
Right, I feel so bad about this.
In fact, I feel so ashamed of it
and I feel like it's my fault.
And so.
Okay, well, let's talk about that.
Right after my brother's death
by suicide, I felt responsible.
I was not involved in
any way in mental health.
I had a business career at the time.
And I finally went and saw someone.
I wasn't acculturated that getting
therapy was something one did.
But I realized, hey, I'm not okay, right?
So I didn't know how.
I just knew the manifestation of
it, which was misery and risk.
And I could just tell, I know
what it feels like to not feel
like this and this is not okay.
So then I call the insurance number.
Eventually I go in and see a therapist.
And I'm sure she was a very good
therapist, but she didn't in the
sense need to be, in the sense
that sometimes we don't need to use
all the things we know we can do,
just something basic with someone.
And that's all she did with me.
I mean, she got me talking about it,
and then I talked about how ashamed
I was because it was my fault.
And then really.
And then she challenged me about
that and then in a nice way.
But then it became clear that I was
so utterly shocked by it, right?
Far from it being
foreseeable to me, right.
That the problem that I was having now
was the shock of it and the sense of
shame and guilt that it raised in me and
then me shoving it under the surface,
not knowing what to do with it, then
it's making all sorts of misery in me,
and I can't actually grieve, right?
So at some point during those sessions,
now I'm sad and I'm crying, right?
And I know what she was thinking, right?
She's good.
Okay.
Thank goodness, this
person getting better.
She probably felt a sense of
relief because she could see,
hey, he's coming out of risk.
He's able to feel sadness,
he's able to grieve.
He's been doing this before.
So it's that work.
Wait, if we put into it that makes
a difference, just as with physical
health, I mean, if I want to be
stronger, I want to be more robust,
like I have to go to the gym and work,
or I have to do something that's hard
work, and then I get the benefit of it.
And the same is true whether we're
reflecting on our life narrative and it
brings some difficult emotions to us,
or whether we're talking with someone
or whether we're doing it in therapy.
But that's how that process of inquiry
leads us, to take some of the Gordian
knots in us, so to speak, and to cut them
instead of trying to figure out, like, how
am I going to feel okay about myself, even
though I'm responsible for my brother's
death, because I should have foreseen it.
I mean, that doesn't work, right?
You have to say, I see what that thing
is, and that has to go away, right?
And then therapy can lead us to
the point where, oh, it wasn't my
fault, and oh my goodness, I'm sad.
Andrew Huberman: I'd like to take
a brief break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors, AG1.
AG1 is a vitamin, mineral,
probiotic drink that meets all of
your foundational nutrition needs.
I started taking AG1 way back
in 2012, so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking AG1, and the
reason I still take AG1 once or generally
twice per day, is that it's the easiest
way for me to ensure that I'm getting
all of the vitamins, minerals, probiotics
and fiber that I need in my diet.
Now, of course, it's essential to get
proper nutrition from whole foods,
but most people, including myself,
find it hard to get enough servings
of fruits and vegetables each day, and
especially to get enough prebiotics
and probiotics to ensure gut health.
As you may know, your gut contains
trillions of little microbiota,
the so called gut microbiome, which
establishes critical connections with
other organs of your body to enhance
brain health, as well as to support your
immune system and other aspects that
relate to mental and physical health.
One of the most common questions I get is,
if you were to take just one supplement,
which supplement would that be?
And my answer is always AG1.
Because by taking AG1, I'm able to
ensure that I'm getting all of the
vitamins, minerals and probiotics that
I need to enhance my mental health,
physical health and performance.
If you'd like to try AG1,
go to drinkag1/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They'll give you five free travel
packs, and they'll give you a
year supply of vitamin D3 K2.
Again, that's drinkag1/huberman
to claim this special offer.
I can see how self inquiry
is really powerful.
I've certainly experienced that in my
own life, and it's an ongoing process.
Right?
This is not something that
one does and then stops.
Ideally, you do it forever,
just like physical fitness.
And at the same time, I know that
a number of people perhaps are
wary of self inquiry, especially
because of the pain points it can
bring about and make conscious and
that we have to really sit with.
And most people would
like to avoid discomfort.
I'm sure there are also people who are
doing quite well in life and therefore
think, oh, pattern of self inquiry.
All it could do, it
sounds like, is more harm.
Like, why would I want to do that?
But I think we both agree that there's
nothing but good and progress and
more agency and gratitude to be had by
going through patterns of self inquiry.
Paul Conti: I think that really
highlights something very important,
which is that self inquiry
isn't always the right answer.
Now, I think just because things are
going well, that doesn't mean self
inquiry isn't the right thing to do.
Self inquiry is always the right
thing to do if we want to understand
ourselves better, unless we're in a
place where it can bring real risk to us.
So when I was trying to think about
myself, inquire, why was I so miserable?
What's going on in me?
I reached a point where I
realized I'm not getting myself
anywhere and I'm getting worse.
And this is not good for me,
because where did this self inquiry
lead me to more guilt and shame?
So then at some point, I sort
of pulled the rip cord right on.
It's like, I can't do
this on my own anymore.
And that's very, very important
to anyone who's listening.
If you feel like, look, I don't think
I'm in a safe or a stable place.
Again, thoughts of self harm, thoughts
of hopelessness, then it probably is not.
Or let's on the side of being cautious.
It is not a good idea then
to engage in self inquiry.
First go see someone clinically.
And I know that can be hard to do in
this day and age, but if we really
advocate for ourselves, we really push,
we do whatever we can do to try and
get in front of someone who can kind
of help us understand what we may need.
And maybe that person helps us
with the process of self inquiry.
Maybe that person reassures us.
Maybe that person then tells us that we
really do need more care, more help, and
then it leads to us getting that so that
we can come back to the good place of
being well enough for the self inquiry.
Andrew Huberman: I'm grateful you shared
your path to working with a clinician and
the fact that just focusing on something
on your own wasn't really working.
And it sounds like a requirement for a
clinician to help guide you through that.
It relates directly to what I'm most
curious about at this moment, which
is in the map that you established
for us in episode one, and that has
carried through all these episodes.
And by the way, if people are not
familiar with the map, we will
cover it in top contour in a little
bit more depth in a moment here.
But one of the key things, or cupboards,
as we're referring to them, to look
in in order to exert self care and
improve one's mental health, is this
notion of self awareness, of really
understanding that there's an I, a me,
and exploring what that's really about
in the moment, but also historically,
through narrative, et cetera.
Also in this map is a cupboard
that relates to salience.
What's most obvious, or what do
we default to both internally, in
terms of what sorts of thoughts we
default to, and externally, what are
we focusing on in the outside world?
And I think I, and perhaps many other
people out there, are wondering how
to resolve any conflict between a
practice that is aimed at increasing
self awareness and perhaps even drawing
to mind early traumas or challenges or
recent traumas or challenges and salience.
In other words, if I were to take some
moments or even an hour once a week and
sit there and really think about the
sorts of things that I don't want to
think about that have been gnawing at me
below the surface for a very long time,
the stuff that I gained some proficiency
at pushing down beneath the surface.
I think one fear that I have, and
so I have to assume other people
have it as well, is that if I were
to bring that to mind, that it would
overtake a lot of my waking hours.
It's like I don't want to think
about this thing or those things.
And so now what's salient
is something negative.
And when I'm focused on something
negative, then I'm not able to be
as generative as I would, like,
move forward toward my life goals.
Now I could even have the realization,
the cognitive understanding that,
okay, but that's necessary, right?
Like, this is like getting a wound
fixed or dealing with a chronic injury.
Like, sooner or later, you got
to deal with it, otherwise you're
not going to be at your best.
But that conflict between gaining more
self awareness and also the understanding
that what is most salient to us kind of
defines the quality of our daily life.
That conflict or friction seems
like an important thing for
us to drill into a little bit.
Paul Conti: Absolutely.
And I would say this.
If you think there's something that you
can't bring up into consciousness because
it's going to take over your mind, or
as people often say, I'm going to curl
up in a fetal position, I'm going to
cry and never stop, that is exactly the
thing you must look at, because salience
presents itself in a whole array of ways.
So if there's something inside of you
that's strong enough that it's throwing
itself up to the surface, like, hey,
maybe you want to think about me.
So your unconscious mind, throwing it up
to the surface, that is active in you.
And often, although a lot of it
happens in the unconscious mind, it
happens also in the conscious mind.
And if the person then stops and thinks,
how much might that thing that you are
not thinking about be impacting you,
how might it be salient in other ways?
And sometimes a person will realize,
like, yeah, that's on my mind.
People say, oh, that's
on my mind all the time.
It's like kind of on the back
burner, but always there.
And he says, right on the back burner.
That's like having a voice in the
background telling you something
very negative or very distressing.
And it's just one example where
oftentimes there's a realization that
that thing is actually quite salient.
Sometimes there isn't a
realization until later.
Oh, the salience of that is, that's
why I don't let myself get ahead.
It can come out later because we don't
know how much of it is unconscious,
how much of it is conscious.
But under the right circumstances, if
things are safe, as we said, if there's
not something going on that presents
risk and warrants clinical care, if
there's something inside of you, and
you think, I can't let that to the
surface, then what that is telling
you is I must let that to the surface.
Now, again, we want to do it in judicious
ways and do it in ways that are safe.
But that's the message.
Andrew Huberman: I think it's especially
important that you mentioned that if
something is gnawing at our conscious
mind every once in a while, then
it absolutely has to be operating
below the level of our conscious.
Paul Conti: Awareness, maybe
running amok all the time.
Level of consciousness.
Andrew Huberman: So if ever
there was a cause for exploring
something like that, that's it.
Because we can't be aware of the ways
that's damaging to us or limiting us.
Again, somebody listening to
this could be doing quite well.
I'm doing great.
Why would I want to do any of this?
Well, perhaps they could
be doing that much better.
Paul Conti: Right, absolutely.
Andrew Huberman: Self awareness and
addressing one's personal narrative
and a sense of eye is what we called
covered one under the function of self.
Now, for those that listen to
episodes one, two or three, they'll
be familiar with what I'm talking
about when I say a covered one.
Function of self.
But just for sake of getting everybody
on the same page as we move forward
here, maybe we could just return to
the map of mental health for a moment.
We've talked about agency and
gratitude as verb states, and
you also described in previous
episodes this key, really essential
concept of this generative drive.
So if you could just take a few minutes
for us and really explain what agency
and gratitude are, how one goes about
building those up and expressing those,
and what the generative drive is.
And then we'll return to the ten cupboards
of inquiry under the structure of self
and function of self, which really
represent the pillars and all the stuff
that geysers up into these simple but
extremely powerful concepts and ways of
being, which are agency and gratitude.
Paul Conti: Yes.
So I really liked when you brought the
image of a geyser to mind, because if
we think about the structure of self,
which is one pillar, and the function
of self, which is another pillar,
underneath those pillars there are the
ten cupboards we've been talking about.
And they represent the areas of inquiry
for us because they're the aspects of
the structure and function of self.
So that's where the answers are.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: The answers
are in those pillars.
The answers are in those ten cupboards.
So if we're doing that, we're looking
there, we're honoring what we find there.
We're becoming healthier than that geyser.
I imagine it coming out the
space in between the pillars.
And what it is lifting up is,
first empowerment and humility.
But empowerment and humility
are qualities, certainly the
way we're using them, they're
qualities, they're potential.
So I have empowerment as
opposed to being disempowered.
So I have humility instead of, for
example, a reactive grandiosity or
even a reactive self oppression.
So I have these qualities of empowerment
and humility, and then they become
enacted, they become expressed by us.
And I imagine riding on the top
is the agency and the gratitude.
It's at the top of the
geyser, and it's moving.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: They're verbs.
We navigate life as life moves forward.
I will often think, like
being on, like, the luge.
And you see in the Olympics where the
prize is going down the twisting path, and
it's like, that's us moving through life.
And we all have different pathways, but
they can interconnect and they can cross.
That's what's happening.
Living is an active thing.
So agency and gratitude are active things.
Why?
Because they're the ultimate expression
of all underneath of it, of them.
That's where it goes.
If the pillars are in the right
place, the geyser can function.
The empowerment and humility are with us.
So we're engaging with ourselves,
with others, with the world, through a
lens of clarity and through a lens of
knowing we can make the world a better
place and knowing our role in it.
That's very, very active.
And then it brings to us the peace,
the contentment, the delight that
weaves in and out, as you described,
that you will feel the peace, the
contentment, the delight, when
you're doing the solo podcasts.
But you're doing something
very, very active.
It's not a passive endeavor during
which you feel all those things.
But that makes sense.
Peace doesn't mean nothingness.
Right?
Now it can.
Someone who's looking out
the window at the garden they
planted can feel that, too.
But there's life going
on in them alSo, right?
They're contemplating the garden.
They know that they made the garden.
So these are all active processes, because
life is an active process, and then we end
up in this place of looking inside of us.
These drives within us are both
deterministic and determined.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: So think about how
active a process that is, where
we have a natural bias one way or
another because of our genetics.
Just like someone has a natural aptitude
to be taller and someone shorter or
to be more or less athletic, we have
potential within us when the genetics
come together, and that may determine
some sort of set of parameters.
So maybe someone who doesn't
have the blessings of being so
athletic, perhaps myself, right?
I'm not going to be the
world's greatest athlete.
But if I work hard, I could be a lot
more athletic and have been at times.
And if I don't, I could
be a lot less athletic.
So there are potentials within us that
get sort of genetically determined, but
have a wide array of variants around them.
And then our choices determine
where we are in that variance.
If I don't take care of myself,
I will be on the very low
end of the athletic spectrum.
If I do and I cultivate myself,
I can be on a higher end for me.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: But still, that's a
lot better than the lower end.
There's a very big difference.
The same is true in our drives.
The more we're taking care of ourselves,
we're reinforcing the primacy of
the generative drive and then the
aggression assertion, proactive.
That drive in us is realized as
best we're going to realize it.
Not everyone's is going to be
off the chart, and that's okay.
But that drive is in a place that lets
that person take care of themselves,
have a job they enjoy and can do
well at, and make their home life
better, whatever it is that we can do.
We're more assertive, we're more engaged,
and then that's bringing us more pleasure.
So the pleasure drive, again,
it's not a hedonistic drive.
It's drive for things we enjoy.
Like we enjoy safety, we enjoy
absence of pain, but we also enjoy
friends and romance and sex and food.
Like these are things that bring
us gratification, and we can
have that in a healthy place too.
So there's not too much, not too
little of the aggression assertion.
Proactive drive, not too much, not
too little of the pleasure drive.
And then we're in a place where we
can meet where those drives are at.
So if the pleasure drive is in a
certain place in us, we can meet that.
And maybe we foster it, moving a little
higher up because we're doing good things
and we're taking care of ourselves.
So if our romance is in a
better place, then we can take
more pleasure in our romance.
If our physical fitness is in a
better place, we can enjoy that more.
We can do more things.
So we are helping those drives to
be in the optimal place to subserve
the generative drive, which we are
trying to optimize and maximize.
And that puts us in the best place to
have the things under those pillars,
in those cupboards, in a good place.
And then on top of that geyser is the
empowerment and the humility, and then
that gets enacted as agency and gratitude,
and we have more of the goodness of
peace and contentment and delight.
And that reinforces the generative drive.
So that's what's going on.
And it has never failed me yet
to read or listen to someone
communicating happiness, either.
What they think it is, how they found
it, what they're striving for, what
they think it philosophically is.
It's all that, and it's not
as simple as a word, right?
Because it's complex.
We're complex, but the beauty of it
all is the complexity is within us, but
it's not out of our reach to understand
ourselves better and help ourselves.
And if we do that, as we move further
up the hierarchy, it gets simpler.
Approaching the world through
agency and gratitude as verbs,
it's pretty straightforward.
That's why that's the best metric
for romantic compatibility, right?
It's not.
This person plays a musical instrument
and that person's a mathematician,
so they're not compatible.
No more than one plays the trumpet,
one plays the clarinet, and
we assume they are compatible.
Where are those drives at?
Are people healthy in a healthy place?
We can then take the best care of
ourselves, engage with others in
a healthy way, understand who's a
healthy other to engage with, get
ourselves out of unhealthy situations.
And then we're building health within
ourselves and around ourselves.
And that's how, at the different
levels of emergence, things get better.
So if I make myself healthier and
you make yourself healthier, we
will be healthier as a group of two.
That's always how that is.
And if we're healthier as a
group of two, we can be healthier
as parts of larger groups.
If the groups aren't healthy, we're
pushing towards greater health.
We're engendering health, and that's
how we see health grow until it
can be manifest, even on a cultural
level, where we're taking better care
of ourselves, we're less punitive,
we're less rushing forward as a
society and trampling the vulnerable.
And we realize, oh, I
could be the vulnerable.
I care about other people, even if
I don't know them, because I can
understand and empathize with what
it feels like to be vulnerable.
And furthermore, I could
be among the vulnerable.
So we behave differently as a culture,
and that's what we're searching
for on an individual level, all
the way up to a cultural level.
Andrew Huberman: I have several
questions, but first, I want to just
highlight what you said about relational
structure, relationships, and the
fact that, as was explored in episode
three, and you made so clear, and
it just makes so much sense, most of
what people explore for when looking
for a romantic partner or determining
whether or not their existing romantic
relationship could be better or not,
is focused on the wrong things, right?
These very kind of superficial
notions of what people enjoy and
even level of education, some of
which can really matter, but that's
not the critical issue at hand.
And that the maps that the two
individuals have and the extent
to which they are expressing their
generative drive and agency and
gratitude is far, far more important.
And so for those that haven't heard
episode three and are interested
in relationships, not just romantic
relationships, but relationships of
all kinds, work, families, relationship
to self, friendship, I highly, highly
recommend listening to that conversation
because it's truly spectacular in
terms of its actionable takeaways.
By actionable I mean actions, of
course, behaviors and also modes of
thinking that can really serve people.
I also just want to make one
clarification that I believe that
when you said hierarchy, when you
said move up the hierarchy, you were
referring to the hierarchy within the
map that's been laid out here, right?
As opposed to.
I don't want people to get mistakenly
distracted by the possibility that
we're talking about some sort of,
like, external social hierarchy.
So I just want to clarify that.
And that's actually a perfect jumping
off place for going into the map
with a little bit more depth and
detail and exploring these cupboards
that reside at the lower levels of
the map and that are quite complex.
Okay, so for those of you listening who
have not yet gone and accessed the PDF
that we've put in the show note captions.
You can do that at any point,
but what we're talking about is a
bunch of things down at the bottom
under these two pillars, structure
of self and function of self.
These cupboards that are extremely
valuable for any and all of us to look in
and explore and ask specific questions,
because it's what resides within those
cupboards that combine in a sort of recipe
and then geyser up into whether or not and
how much empowerment, humility, agency,
gratitude, peace, contentment, delight,
and generative drive we are able to exert
and experience for ourselves in life.
So imagine in your minds, if you
will, and here I'm borrowing directly
from a picture model that Dr.
Conti provided before the filming
of this series, which is an iceberg
where below the surface of the
water resides a bunch of stuff.
And then a little bit is above the water.
And maybe you'll help us revisit
that model now for a few moments.
But if you take nothing away at this
moment, please understand that there's a
lot of complex stuff going on underneath
the surface of the brain and mind.
But a key feature of this map is that
while it is very, very complex underneath,
what emerges from that complexity
gets simpler and simpler, especially
as we move towards places of better
health and more effectiveness in life.
So if you would, could you describe
the map in a bit more detail,
especially what's down there in these
pillars, the complex stuff and the
stuff that we should be looking at.
And then we'll touch on some of
those cupboards that we all have
and the sorts of questions that we
should all be asking in the context
of some common challenges, but also
some very common and very effective
paths to doing and feeling better.
Paul Conti: Yes, the unconscious
mind is the place to start.
That's the deepest level
of the structure of self.
So imagine sitting on top of a biological
supercomputer the size of a house.
That's what's going on inside of us.
The unconscious mind is that
biological supercomputer.
And if we're interested in ourselves,
we become very, very curious
about what is going on in it.
And that's where, even though it's not
directly accessible to us, it can be
accessible through other ways, such as
we talked about reflection or therapy.
And of course, there are other ways
too, but it is accessible to us, and we
want to know what is in it, because what
is in it has such a strong effect on
what's going on in our conscious mind.
That's the person on top of the biological
supercomputer, the size of a house or the
image we've been using, is the top of the
iceberg that's coming out of the water.
So we can look at that either way.
But what is in it has, of course,
a huge effect on the part that
we're aware of, our conscious mind.
And I think the best analogy here, and
it's actually, I think, quite an analogy
that parallels very well, is to an
abscess in the field of physical medicine.
So an abscess is an area
of walled off infection.
So imagine that there's some infection,
for example, it's often in the abdomen,
there's some infection, and that
infection could be really dangerous.
If that infection spread, boy,
it could go to the blood, the
person could die from that, right?
So the body does a really good
job of walling off that infection.
And that's a good thing, right?
Because if the infection weren't
walled off, it poses huge risk.
But the walled off infection does
not represent a condition of health.
So someone who has an abscess
in them and doesn't know it.
This happens frequently in medicine,
and we see people coming to emergency
rooms, and they have a low grade
fever, and they've had a low grade
fever for a while, and they just don't
feel good, and they have low energy,
and they're not sleeping well, and
they find themselves sweating a lot.
There are pervasive experiences going
on that are really detracting from life.
Like not feeling great all the
time, even though the person
doesn't feel really sick.
That's sometimes why it takes a while for
the person to come to medical attention.
So what's going on is better
than not being walled off.
But it is not synonymous with health.
So what happens in physical medicine?
Abscess is identified,
and then someone goes in.
The surgeon goes in and drains
it, and then the person is better.
Now, think about that process.
Like surgery.
Surgery is not a fun thing.
Right?
There's anesthesia, there's recovery.
But surgery is great when
it cures the problem.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: So it's not that, oh, the
physician in the emergency room or
the family practice doc identifies
that there's an abscess, refer to
the surgeon, everything is great
and happy, and they're better.
No, they have to go have a surgery,
and that's not an easy thing.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: But if they go and
do that on the other side, the
infection actually is gone.
So they do not have the
symptoms that it was constantly
spinning off inside of them.
And they also don't have the risk that
maybe that infection gets out of the
abscess and their life is then at risk.
So the parallel is looking into the
unconscious mind to what is inside of
us that may be acting like that abscess.
Even though this is an
analogy, it is not theoretical.
This happens all the time.
And the abscess inside that person
emotionally may be the bullying that
went on right around the time of puberty.
It may be that awful boss who is just so
mean and took that good job away from me.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: It might be that.
It might be that assault that
I don't want to think about
that's really still with me.
It might be that death I
still feel guilty about.
I don't know what it is.
But if there's an abscess in
there, we want to understand
it and then fix it, cure it.
And that's what the
therapy process can do.
And that's why at times,
therapy is unpleasant.
The crying and the anger.
That's the parallel of
going through the surgery.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: But on the other side, we've
dissipated the energy inside of it.
We've taken care of it.
And that's why it is so important to
go into the unconscious mind if there
are things that are really troubling
us or if we don't know what's going on,
to cast a net of inquiry that may lead
us there, because trauma is so common,
and we shove trauma underneath the
surface because of the guilt and shame
that it generates, and then it stays
in us like an abscess and spins off.
Symptoms, they could be symptoms
of diffidence, they could be
symptoms of overusing a substance.
They could be symptoms of
avoiding good things in our life.
But they're pervasive symptoms
that are really harmful to us,
that we can understand and fix.
Andrew Huberman: In addition to
quality therapy, what are some other
ways to access the unconscious?
Earlier we were talking about journaling
and spelling out one's life narrative
in written or in spoken form, either
alone or with a trusted other.
Let's assume that somebody either can't
afford or is just not at the place
where they're willing to do therapy yet.
But they fully adopt this abscess
model, or this abscess analogy that
you described, which I think is an
exceptional one, because, a, you
have the 20 plus years of clinical
experience knowing this exists.
But also, I think we all, at some level
kind of understand that there's stuff
happening within us that we can't explain.
And I, as a neuroscientist, can absolutely
say that most of the neural machinery in
your head and the parts of it that are
in your body, we don't have access to it.
We love to think that we do, but we don't.
It's just clicking away under there.
So let's say somebody wants to make some
progress, really improve their level
of mental health, obtain more agency
and gratitude, improve all aspects of
their life and their generative drive.
What are some ways that they can
start to tap into the unconscious?
And my guess is, if it's not in
therapy, it's going to be by looking
at in some of these other cupboards
as you're describing them, right?
Paul Conti: Yes.
Develop and embrace
curiosity about yourself.
And if you can go for that curiosity,
being dispassionate in the sense
that you talk about these files
you have with memories and events
from your past, that's so good,
because you're exploring your life.
So someone who wants to understand
themselves better, do that for yourself.
Go look at pictures, talk to people
you knew at different stages of life,
reflect upon how you behaved at different
stages of life, what you felt inside.
Anchor yourself to memories and
then extrapolate from there.
Become curious about yourself,
and if you can, be dispassionate.
This idea that sometimes
gets called an observing ego.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: There are other
words to put to it, but it's
not ego in a negative sense.
Here, it means the ability to
stand outside of oneself and go.
And to really think about oneself
without the negative emotion, we're
often able to either see the trauma,
for example, or see the change.
Like, why did I go from feeling
really good about myself, and I
felt like I could do anything?
And then just a couple of
years later, man, look at me,
I'm mopey in the pictures.
And then, yeah, I was drinking more.
I stopped taking care of myself.
That's a pretty big change, right?
So now we're calling attention.
What's that change?
And a lot of times, the person knew it.
Like, oh, I got rejected.
I had that terrible breakup.
And they knew it was a
terrible breakup, but they keep
shoving it under the surface.
Maybe they didn't know it
was a terrible breakup.
Maybe they can't figure out what it is.
That's okay, right?
Even if they recognize, look, there was
a change, then that will put the lie to
what in this example is likely going on.
So that person likely frames
themselves in a way that is very
negative and always was true.
Right?
I can never achieve anything.
I never feel good.
No one likes me.
I can't find a partner.
Whatever it is we say to ourselves,
it's always been that way.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: Because the negative emotion
is so strong, and that part of our brain
doesn't care about the clock and the
calendar, and then the person goes back
and thinks, it was not always that way.
Right?
And it comes to this a lot in therapy.
It doesn't have to be,
as you said, in therapy.
But, no, I was a go getter.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: I'm thinking of the person
who said that I was a go getter, and
I went out there and did things which
put the lie to her, saying that she was
lazy, incapable, all those things that
were not true, but she accepted as truth.
So she needed, from that
mathematical perspective, like, to
go back and question the givens.
From our perspective, we're saying,
go look in the unconscious mind.
Go look in that part of the
pillar of the structure of self.
Go look there.
That's the deepest part, the most
complicated part, but it doesn't
mean we can't understand it.
And if we start to gain
understanding, then we can think
more about the conscious mind.
Like, wait a second,
what am I thinking about?
What do I think about that?
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: Have I really
thought about this?
Or is it just running
over and over in my head?
What would I like to do about it?
Maybe I'd like to learn more.
Maybe I want to go get a book that I think
could help me listen to another podcast
that could help me talk to a friend.
Like, maybe I want to do those things.
So now the flow between the
unconscious mind and the conscious
mind becomes much more robust.
And that lets us look further to look at
the next level up, the defense mechanisms
that grow up out of the unconscious mind,
and we can have some understanding of
them even though they're unconscious.
So the idea of wait, when something
shifted in me, how did my way of
engaging with the world kind of change?
I was perseverant.
And I would take some of that
energy in me that wasn't so good.
And remember, I could put it into
exercising and taking care of myself.
And then that sort of shifted and
I became sarcastic and cynical,
and I started avoiding those of my
friends who are really taking care
of themselves and doing well, because
that made me feel worse about myself.
That's a dialogue that is
reflective of defense mechanisms.
Now the person isn't going to
necessarily say, oh, I used a lot of
sublimation, which is good, and then
I started using reaction formation
and avoidance just as an example.
But they're going to understand that
in words, that whatever words they put
to it, they understand that there was
a change, they put words to that they
can understand that process of change.
It's not opaque.
They're shining light on it.
And now they can gain a
better understanding of
it and they can change it.
Even that realization that I was much
more functional, things were different.
I mean, that can be a treasure trove
of very relevant, very important
and very positive information to
bring to the current situation.
Andrew Huberman: I think we often romance
the idea of the person who can just
live life forward, who doesn't look
back, who just doesn't really explore
their past, is just action oriented.
Because after all, when we wake up
in the morning, all we can control
is our actions going forward.
We can't rescript the actions
of past, ours or others.
Paul Conti: That is such a
good point of what happens when
we're just looking forward.
We become like a sprinter who
comes out of the blocks too fast.
So if you think about the beginning
of a 100 meters dash, they're the
best sprinters in the world, say,
and there they are in the blocks.
And if they come out of those blocks
in the right way, they will gain
momentum, they will keep their form,
and they will run as fast as they can.
But if they do not pay attention
to what is behind them, the blocks
that are supporting their body.
The whole bigger picture here of
the limitations within the body.
They have to know what
those limitations are.
They have to understand themselves.
That's how they avoid coming out
of the block so fast and then
sprawling headlong onto the track.
And we see that happen, too.
So if we're just looking forward and
thought and idea, that's how to live
life, we will be tripping forward, and
ultimately, we'll be like that sprinter.
No matter how great a sprinter,
if you come out of the blocks too
fast, you're going to trip forward.
Andrew Huberman: Yes, I know I said this
in a different form a few minutes ago,
but I think a lot of people are afraid
of self inquiry, because they just
don't want the thing that they discover
which resides in their unconscious, the
abscess, if you will, or the damaging
thought or thing that happened, which
they are aware of, but are pushing down
to take over their daily life in a way
that doesn't allow them to be at least
as functional as they are in the moment.
Paul Conti: If you go visit the
person who had the abscess cured
by the surgeon on postop day one,
that person will be less functional.
They'll be in a hospital bed.
They won't be able to
get up out of the bed.
They won't be able to exercise.
They're going to feel their best.
That's okay.
It is okay that we, at times, can become
intermittently, say, less functional.
In the sense that we're more upset
that I'm spending more time crying.
That's okay.
Because that's part of the
energy, the effort, the choice
that gets us to a better place.
Andrew Huberman: Ok so it's clear to me
why exploring the unconscious mind can
be and really is immensely valuable.
I'm convinced.
And I can't imagine anyone out there
who would disagree with the idea that
getting better mentally, being able
to function better in the world as a
consequence, is not a terrific use of
one's time, even if it, at the surface
seems to take us off course a bit in
the moment or for even a few days.
And I think it's also worth highlighting
that it's not the case that if we
do an exploration of the unconscious
mind, or look in any of these covered,
for that matter, that our entire day
is going to be overtaken by it or all
of our sleep is going to disappear.
I mean, we're not talking about
a process in which everything is
devoted to exploring these cupboards.
I mean, there are instances, of
course, where someone hits a crisis
and they simply can't function.
But in that case, the thing
they absolutely need to do is
to look in these cupboards.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: What are some ways that
we can explore this other cupboard under
the pillar of structure of self, which
is the cupboard of the conscious mind.
Paul Conti: So we can also approach
this through the curiosity of self.
We do a lot of things automatically
that we can stop and think about.
Like, why do I do that thing?
And it's amazing what that can provide.
So, for example, I'm working with
a person who has been going to work
for a long, long, long time, didn't
need to go to work a long time ago.
And there's so many other things this
person wants to do with their life.
They're curious about things, they want
to spend more time with older people
in their family, but they had to stop
and think, why am I going to work?
Now he's fortunate enough
that he doesn't have to.
He also earned.
He's hardworking, he's diligent, he's
fortunate, but he hadn't thought about it.
He's been going to work
automatically for a long time.
And it was the thinking about it that made
him realize, I do that automatically now.
Why?
Because it's rooted in unconscious
things but that he's now
bringing to the conscious mind.
Because I value hard work
and I value diligence.
But him stop working doesn't mean that
he's not innately hardworking or diligent.
He showed that for years and years and
years, and he can show it in other ways.
Like by he wants to be attentive
to older people who need help.
There's a lot he can do.
But he had to go back and look.
And then, of course, there's a reason
why he didn't realize it, right?
And even though it's not even a bad
reason, but clearly there was an
overvalue of hardworking diligent, and
he didn't realize, oh, I've done that.
I've done enough that I've convinced
myself, I know I'm hardworking, I know
I'm diligent, so I don't have to sort
of serve that internal master anymore.
And I can step away.
And now his whole life has changed.
But how did the change come about?
By asking what might one might think
is such a simple question to make no
sense, like why do I go to work each day?
Why have I been going?
He's off on the road to change.
It's one aspect of how we can
explore the conscious mind.
It often leads us back to the
unconscious mind, but it's
awareness of our conscious choices.
We can also then use tactics.
So, for example, cognitive behavioral
tactics like thought redirection.
Like if I'm aware that, hey, there's
a thought that comes into my mind
a lot, and I start learning ways I
can redirect away from it instead of
thinking about it 100 times, right?
And if I learn how to do that, there's
less sort of negative emotion that
comes from thinking about it and
I can start to feel better, right?
It's the basic premise of it.
But these are techniques that can really
help us and they involve understanding
and guiding the conscious mind.
Andrew Huberman: I'm smiling because
I'm recalling an experience I had.
I have a female friend who, very
impressive person, really is overcomeaton
is a recovered alcoholic for many years
and takes, at least by my read, great
care of herself and the other people
around her, and has a spectacular sense
of humor and a bunch of other things.
But it's probably five, six years ago that
we were in conversation about something,
I don't recall what, and out of apparently
nowhere she said, I hate being busy.
And it just stopped me in my
tracks because I'm somebody
who keeps very, very busy.
My schedule is extremely full with
things that I really enjoy, some
things I don't enjoy or enjoy less.
But fortunately, at this point in my
life, mostly things that I enjoy at the
time, I was very busy with many things,
including many things I didn't enjoy.
And her statement just halted me.
And I realized maybe I
don't have to be busy.
This whole notion of doing a bunch
of things I don't want to do, sure,
we have to make our way in the
world and make a living and take
care of ourselves and others, but
I realized that there was a lot of
extra stuff that I was doing, right.
Paul Conti: Because I think what she
meant and what you were reflecting on was,
I hate being automatically busy, right
? It's not good to be automatically busy.
And then it makes you think about, wait,
how am I busy in ways that are good for
me and how am I busy in ways that are not?
Am I just taking up
time to avoid something?
You start really thinking about it.
Andrew Huberman: Yes.
And the conversation stays with me to
this day, because up until then, I never
really thought about the possibility
that some or a lot of the things I was
doing were truly a waste of my time.
Mostly because I could be putting that
energy into generative things, right?
Generative tribes, things that would bring
me agency, gratitude, peace, contentment,
delight, these sorts of things.
What I'm giving as an example, I
realize, is quite different than
sitting down in a chair and asking
oneself questions about oneself and
one's schedule and what one's doing.
Paul Conti: Same endpoint?
Andrew Huberman: Same endpoint.
And I bring it up because I think
it was the fact that it stopped
me in my tracks, but also the fact
that I can't seem to forget it.
That means that it must have had
significance, and I would say has
had significance, because I think
most people are familiar with seeing
these news articles that come out.
You know, woman or man, 104, reflects
on what really mattered in life.
And it's almost always the same things.
It's like close relationships.
No one on their deathbed says, I
wish I spent more time at work.
I might be one exception.
I actually really enjoy my work.
So whenever I see that one, I always
think, no, my life without my life's work,
it would been a diminished life for me.
I think there are others
out there as well.
But I think it's very hard for us to
place ourselves into the future of a
person on our deathbed, looking back,
and then make really good decisions now.
I think there are ways to do that, but
it seems that it's far more powerful to
just think about what am I doing now?
And come to some realizations about
what is really of value now and what
is of less value or no value now,
and then make adjustments now, as
opposed to doing the deathbed exercise.
Paul Conti: You have no other option
if you're going to make change.
I mean, think about what a complicated
and ultimately meaningless exercise
it is to try and project ahead into a
future when one is on one's deathbed
and it's like, what is that like?
We can't imagine that and
we don't know who's there.
Whatever that situation may be for any of
us, it's not going to be what we imagine.
So then we just make something up and we
try and what, extrapolate our lives in a
way that gets us to this place where we're
on our deathbed and we're not unhappy.
Okay?
It just brings us right back to the
future because it's actually simple.
That is so complicated.
What are things going to
be like on our deathbed?
What will happen between now and then?
All things, I don't know.
So it's impossibly complicated.
So then you take it back
to the present, right?
Like what is it I'm choosing?
I am the I right now that is moving
through time or is on the luge of
life or whatever we want to say.
So what am I choosing right now?
That's how we make our lives better.
And we're aware, of course, I
know there's a future I want to
lead towards a better future.
I don't have a crystal ball.
I can't envision what that's going to be.
But I can do my best now to guide my
life as best I can, and that's going
to have to lead me to the best future.
Whatever all the variables
are that I don't know yet.
Andrew Huberman: The next cupboard
under the pillar of structure
of self is defense mechanisms.
I have several questions about defense
mechanisms, but the first question is,
can we be aware of our defense mechanisms?
And is there value in that?
And if so, which defense
mechanisms are accessible to us?
And I guess the third question
would be, how does one go about
exploring defense mechanisms?
Paul Conti: Well, it's sort of fantastical
imagery that there's this iceberg, right?
Part is underwater, part is above
water, and then from the part that's
underwater come these sort of branches.
So the way I imagine it is there are
branches of ice that can be clear
and have light pass through them
in a way that has high fidelity.
Or they can be sort of twisted
and unclear and they distort the
light that passes through them.
Now they rise up from the unconscious
mind, meaning defenses are unconscious,
they're automatic, but they're not outside
of our ability to go looking for them.
They're in the unconscious mind.
It's not that we can't understand
them, it's that they're elusive and
there has to be a process of inquiry.
But we can learn about them just
like we can learn about other
things in the unconscious mind.
And here again, knowledge is power.
So I'm not going to learn anything
new, or I'm unlikely to learn anything
new about my defense mechanisms if
I don't think about them, right?
But if I start to think about
them, then I can start to learn
things and to draw conclusions.
How am I behaving now
as opposed to before?
Do I notice that?
How I'm coping?
We'll often think coping, but coping
is conscious, but we can access that.
How am I coping?
What am I doing and what does it mean?
For example, someone who after
some difficult experience then
starts avoiding, can be doing
that without an awareness of it.
Avoidance is a defense so
avoidance of situations or people
or potential negative emotion.
So self reflection can help us understand
which defense mechanisms we're using
and what may have changed in us.
So an example, and an example we see
all the time is someone who, say,
had as a primary defense mechanism,
sublimation before some difficult event.
And sublimation is taking energy,
taking, say, excess aggression,
turning it into something positive.
It's a good way of handling
distress within us.
It's healthy, right?
And now, after some change in
their life, they find that, say
they're drinking more and they're
relying more and more on alcohol.
And you might say, well,
they're soothing with alcohol.
Yes, they're soothing with alcohol in
one sense, but what else might that mean?
And oftentimes what you'll see is maybe
the person is using alcohol because
they're mad at someone, they're punishing
someone, that someone is probably them.
They get to have the short term
soothing, but then to feel worse
about themselves the next day, right?
And the alcohol is in part a search
for soothing, but it's in part an
acting out against the self, which
is a different kind of defense
mechanism that is not healthy.
So the process of reflection or of
inquiry can help us understand the
branches that are coming up from the
iceberg, from the unconscious mind.
How are they in me?
Are they arranged in a way that's sort of
elegant and they're clear and the light
is passing through them, or are there
things that have become sort of twisted?
Okay, what exactly is that?
How do I go change that?
I don't want that branch that is
sort of opaque and that the light
can't get through or is distorted.
So I can go look at that.
Because even though defense mechanisms
are unconscious, if I'm working on
myself, I can take away that, so
to speak, diseased branch, right?
Or that branch that's not healthy and
put in its place something healthier.
That's how we can change
our defensive structure.
Those branches of our defense mechanisms.
Because even though they're unconscious,
we can reflect on them, bring them to
consciousness, and then bring ourselves
to bear to make ourselves healthier.
And it can indeed get healthier.
And as it gets healthier, it affects
the next level around it, which is
the person's character structure.
So, remembering, we're using
fantastical imagery, right?
Because around the iceberg, below and
above the water, and the branches that
come out of the part of the iceberg
under the water and how they array
themselves, we're imagining that
there's a nest that's encompassing
all of that, the unconscious mind, the
conscious mind, the defense mechanisms.
And that nest is the character structure.
It's a way that we contain and define
the self that rides on top of everything.
It is into that nest that the self
settles and from which the self grows.
Because the character structure, it's
more than just the conscious mind.
It's sort of the conscious mind in action,
the defense mechanisms in action, all the
things that are going on underneath the
surface in the unconscious mind in action.
And then that's how we be, you
think be as an active word, right?
That's how we are, or that's how
we actively be in the world, how
we're engaging with the world.
Andrew Huberman: So you described the
character structure as the nest that
is up above the surface of the water,
and that includes things like these
unconscious defenses and all other
aspects of what comes from below.
Then you also said that the self,
ourselves reside in that nest.
I don't recall the exact wording,
but you said something to the extent
of the self grows within that nest.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: And as you said that,
I immediately had the image in mind
of a nest that is either incredibly
nurturing and can really foster the self
in its best ways and can give rise to
empowerment, humility, agency, gratitude,
peace, contentment, delight, generative
drive, all these wonderful things.
I also imagined a nest that isn't as
clean as it could be or that has some
holes in it, or that isn't stable in
the wind and these sorts of things.
Is that sort of imagery
that's coming to mind for me?
Is that a decent way
to conceptualize this?
Paul Conti: Yes, and I think
it is a very important point.
The self nests in the character
structure, and from nesting in
the character structure, it grows.
We are the self that grows
from within that nest.
And that tells us a couple of things.
One, I am something now, right now.
The things I've done, the
things I've thought, the things
that have happened to me.
Like there's a self now.
So one might think then what grows
out of the nest is what I am now.
Hence the concept of acceptance of self.
That's what I am now.
But I am also responsible
for tending what is growing.
I'm responsible for weeding it.
I'm responsible for planting
healthy seeds in it.
And I think that captures the truth
of the acceptance of ourselves.
This is what I am now.
This is who I am now.
But isn't it beautiful that
I can tend and nurture it?
And we know, as you'd commented,
what happens if you don't tend it.
There's a lot of weeds.
Things aren't going well.
Things start to get unstable.
That's not good.
And we can go that way too, right?
That's where agency, gratitude, part
of how it all cycles through, right?
Because our unconscious mind is still
working like it's all still happening.
And that's how we tend that
garden of the self, so to speak.
That's how we best tend it, so that
what grows up from it is a self
that we recognize in the way that
we want to recognize ourselves.
We see a self that we can feel proud of.
We see a self that we understand
well enough to guide forward.
We see a self for which we have
enough respect and humility
within us to understand that
we don't understand everything.
And it's from that self that
we engage with the world.
Andrew Huberman: I've heard many times
before, kind of in the circles of
psychology and self help and elsewhere,
that we need to all learn to mother and
father ourselves to some extent, and I'm
not a developmental psychologist, but
my understanding is that the unconscious
mind, the conscious mind, our defense
mechanisms, the character structure, all
the stuff that makes up the nest which
the self resides and hopefully can grow,
are at least at some stage of life,
perhaps all stages of life, determined
by genetics and by how we were raised.
Nature and nurture.
But this phrase, we have to learn
to parent ourselves, is thrown
around a lot these days, certainly
on social media, but elsewhere too.
And oftentimes that brings to mind sort
of stereotypes of mothering and fathering.
And these stereotypes break
down quite a bit these days.
Things like we have to be
nurturing to ourselves.
Self respect, self love, self protection.
Right?
Healthy self protection
and these kinds of things.
And all of that sounds fine and good,
but it's always seemed rather vague to
me if I'm telling myself I'm okay, or
is that mothering and fathering myself?
I don't know.
It doesn't seem as concrete as
perhaps I would like and others
would like because it's not spelling
out to specific actionables.
What you're describing here makes so
much more sense to me, even though some
of these concepts are a bit abstract,
because the idea of this nest in which
the self resides and emerges from
character structure, one can immediately
see why it's so valuable, and it's
such a key component of mental health
and self care to tend to that nest.
And written into that is the fact
that the nest is malleable, that
we really can make changes, right?
That we can create a better
internal environment for ourself
by going through these cupboards.
Paul Conti: You're pointing out another
crucial factor here, which is if I am
the garden of self that grows up from
all of it, and I am responsible for
tending the garden, I'm also responsible
for tending to the whole structure.
And that's so important if I'm going
to take care of myself in the ways that
we've talked about, I'm going to tend
not just to the garden that's growing
out that I can see on the surface,
But I'm going to attend to all of
me, to the entire structure of self.
An example here that I think can
illustrate it pretty well is so
imagine a person who's doing well.
The part of the iceberg under
the water is solid, right?
The consciousness on top is solid.
The defense mechanisms are
clear, the nest is good, the
garden of self is flourishing.
And then there's a significant
trauma to that person.
There's a car accident, someone is
hurt, there's a death of someone
around them, they have a serious
illness, they lose a job, right?
It can even be they spent too much
time contemplating and looking at
news from murders around the world.
And all the awful things that
we can spend too much time with.
Something traumatic then goes
into the unconscious mind, right?
The trauma happens, and what often
happens, not always, but what very
often happens is the guilt and shame
that are raised cause us to push
the trauma underneath the surface.
Now, that's in the unconscious
mind, and it's impacting it.
And that stability is threatened, right?
I mean, it's all riding on top of
this giant part of the iceberg that's
underneath the surface of the water.
And, okay, we don't have to worry too much
about it if things are going well, but
if it starts to get fragmented, it starts
to shift, it threatens everything that
rides on top of it, which is why taking
care of ourselves means taking care of
all elements of the structure of self.
Andrew Huberman: That all makes very
clear why tending to the garden is so
key, and why we as individuals are really
the people most fit to do this, right?
Of course, when one can, that
work should be done with somebody
who's a really terrific clinician
to help guide that process.
And where one can't work with a
clinician, one would hope that they
would take a structured approach to
this, which is really what we're talking
about here and in the other episodes.
Paul Conti: And keeping in mind.
Keeping in mind that tending to
the self means tending to the
whole structure of self, right?
If we keep that in
mind, we won't go wrong.
We'll pay attention to the surface,
but we'll pay attention to the
things that are under the surface.
We pay attention to the
whole structure of self.
We will shepherd ourselves
forward as best we can.
Andrew Huberman: I'd love for you to
tell us about the function of self, the
second pillar that resides alongside
structure of self, and that serves to
geyser up into how we show up in the
world, hopefully with empowerment,
humility, agency and gratitude.
But sometimes, no.
And as we've established, there
is always, always tremendous value
to exploring these cupboards.
So how does one go about
exploring the different cupboards
under the function of self?
And we should probably start that
conversation by saying, what are the
cupboards under the function of self?
Paul Conti: I'll start off by
saying all the cupboards under the
function of self will reference the
structure of self, which makes sense.
There's a structure, and the
function arises from the structure.
It's good for us to have that in
mind as we're thinking about the
elements of the function of self.
So the deepest element, let's
say the bottom of the pillar,
is self awareness, right?
The sense of an I on top of that.
Next up the pillar are
defense mechanisms in action.
Up from that is salience.
What we're paying attention
to inside and out.
The next level above that is behavior,
and on top of that is our strivings.
So if we go back to the bottom
layer, the deepest, most complicated
layer, it's the sense of self
awareness, the sense of an I.
And there are a lot of ways that
we can foster self awareness.
So, like the unconscious mind in the
structure, we can't just go there and
fully understand what the I is, but we can
do things that can really, really help us.
So for me, thinking about what am
I, and how am I navigating the world
and having in mind the structure
of self, like, right, there's an
unconscious mind working its way in me.
There's my conscious mind.
Even being aware of the first pillar
can be part of fostering the self
awareness of the second pillar.
Another way that can
happen is self reflection.
For some people, it can happen in
meditation, contemplation of the self.
There are many ways that we can
help ourselves understand that
living is an active process.
That idea of the luge of time and
we're moving down it, it's an active
process, and that is the I that
I'm guiding through that process.
We can foster self awareness in
a number of ways, but what we're
trying to do here, the same as with
the bottom of the structure of self,
pillar the most complicated parts.
There's a lot that's unconscious.
There's a lot that's unknown to us.
So what we're trying to do is know some
of it and know more of it over time.
Bring some of those automatic
or unconscious things to
conscious awareness so that we
can have a better understanding.
Because if we have an
understanding, we can utilize
that to make everything better.
Andrew Huberman: I can see right off how
this first cupboard of self awareness and
an exploration of the eye is so critical.
And realizing that we have a physical
body, that we have agency in the
world to do least certain things.
And in an earlier episode, you mentioned
a practice, actually, of looking in the
mirror and focusing on this reality,
that we have a physical body, we
reside in it, and then we have agency.
We can do things in the world as
a way to reinforce self awareness.
Such an interesting practice, and one
that I started on immediately after.
Paul Conti: Really?
Andrew Huberman: Well, that evening.
Yeah.
And the next morning, after hearing it
from you, some interesting things came to
mind, and I encourage people to try it.
It's done.
Eyes opened.
Just for a few minutes or so.
Two, three minutes.
In my case, some interesting understanding
came about, especially when coupled
with thinking about some of my life
narrative and things that have happened.
So I highly recommend people explore
this practice that you described.
I'm also interested in the sorts of
narratives that we have about ourselves.
I think everyone has narratives about
what they're good at, what they're
less good at, what's happened to
them, why it's happened to them.
Could you tell us what you think
about exploring our narratives?
Not just exploring the fact that we
have a physical body, but exploring
our stories about ourselves.
Paul Conti: Well, self awareness
is just the awareness of an I.
So we can use our conscious
mind to help that.
So this aspect of function of self
isn't about what the narrative means.
That comes later.
This is about the awareness of an I.
So when you were talking about the
narrative, you said something along
the lines of, like, there's stories,
and you're not thinking of, like, oh,
it's the same me in these stories.
If you approached the narrative
in a different way, the awareness,
like, there's an I, right?
There's a me.
Like, I'm the point of all these
stories.That's why they're here.
They're all in me in some way or another
because I remember them, and they're
important enough that I wrote them down.
If you look at it that way, where you're
just apprehending an I, like, there's
a me, to whom all of this applies.
That's how we can use the
conscious mind and the narrative
in order to foster self awareness.
It's not yet about meaning.
It's about the awareness of an I.
Andrew Huberman: So it's actually much
simpler than I'm making it out to be.
At some level?
Paul Conti: At that level, yes.
Andrew Huberman: Got it.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Ok.
Andrew Huberman: Well, then
at some point, we will return
to this theme of narratives.
Narratives that serve us, perhaps
narratives that don't serve us.
Meanwhile, take us into that second
bin under the function of self,
the defense mechanisms in action.
I find these infinitely fascinating,
and I think many other people do
too, because sublimation, denial,
these kinds of things, they really
provide so much of what does and
doesn't happen to each of us.
If you could tell us how we can think
about our defense mechanisms in action
in a way that can improve our health.
Paul Conti: Yeah, of course.
Defense mechanisms are
under the structure of mind.
Defense mechanisms in action
are under function of mind.
They're unconscious processes
that we can gain sometimes a very
good understanding of by directing
our conscious mind towards them.
And this is a place where we
can use narratives, we can
use an understanding of self.
So as an example, someone who's
thinking about themselves and what
they want to do for a living, if they
want their job or where they want to
live, and who's thinking about self
can realize he's going to feel good
when I'm doing something for someone.
When we hear this a lot, especially
people who then direct themselves
towards helping professions, like,
what did I like about that job?
It wasn't that it had a great salary.
It wasn't that the hours were good.
I like that it was really helpful
to people, or there were people that
were underneath of me in the hierarchy
that I could really kind of nurture.
Right.
And I think, right, and I love putting
food out for the birds and the squirrels.
It can be a realization of self
that guides us towards consciously
apprehending and thinking about
altruism as a defense mechanism.
Because altruism is a defense.
It's a healthy defense where if you can
do something good, you do something good.
Make something good.
That's the endpoint of it.
Like, you don't need that to
translate into something else.
It's a defense mechanism.
It's a good one.
And you can certainly see how it
fits with the good things we're
trying to build on top of it.
And sometimes through that process of
reflection, the person becomes aware
of that they haven't chosen jobs by the
obvious things that even they thought
they chose jobs by where is the job?
What does it pay?
It wasn't that.
That what they really valued and what
they then started choosing upon might
have been something that they weren't
aware of until they think about it.
And that leads them to the
defense mechanism the same way.
Another example could be
rationalization, right?
Someone who thinks about their
life and they think, you know, at
least kind of tell myself something
is better than it is, right?
And then ultimately I'm
disappointing myself.
I tell myself, like, you're
doing really well at work and I'm
not really working hard enough.
And then when I have that
review, I feel lousy.
And that last person who broke
up with me and said, you just
weren't being a reliable partner,
or that person was right, and that
can lead to, oh, what's going on?
I always think things are going
pretty well when they're not.
That's guiding us towards
rationalization as a defense mechanism.
And again, a person doesn't have
to say, ah, I conclude I am using
rationalization as a defense mechanism.
But there can be words put to that
of seeing a pattern in the self.
When this is done as part of therapeutic
inquiry, we're often looking to identify
the defense mechanisms, and that can be
great too, but it's not always needed.
Defense mechanisms result in patterns.
So if a person just sees the pattern,
that can be enough to recognize the
pattern and either, say, follow the
pattern of altruism as a defense
mechanism, or how do we work against,
how do I work against the pattern of
rationalization as a defense mechanism?
Andrew Huberman: Can we conclude
that patterns that we don't like
are the reflection of unhealthy
defense mechanisms, and that patterns
that we like are the consequence
of healthy defense mechanisms?
Paul Conti: Usually, yes.
It's worth some thought and some
reflection and putting together like,
what exactly are the pieces of that?
But basically the answer to that is yes.
Andrew Huberman: In an earlier
episode, you mentioned one defense
mechanism in action that is often
observed in people is acting out.
This immediately sounds like
an unhealthy defense mechanism.
So to keep with this concept of the
patterns are often more observable than
are the underlying defense mechanisms.
Would it be the case, for instance,
that if somebody has a repeated set
of failures, that's a pattern, or is
repeatedly in friction in a particular
relationship in their life, maybe
even just with one person, like
all other relationships are going
great, but then they're in a lot of
friction with this one other person.
So there's a pattern from that
pattern they could explore.
What is it important that they get to
a verbal identification of the defense
mechanism or what sorts of steps would
one take going from a recognition
of the pattern to understanding
of the defense mechanism, perhaps
in a way that moves them forward?
Paul Conti: The understanding of the
defence mechanism can be very helpful,
but isn't always needed, right.
If you can recognize a maladaptive
pattern like, oh, this is happening
a lot and it's not good for me, you
become able to change that pattern.
So understanding the
defense can be helpful.
I mean, again, the more
understanding the better.
But it's not always necessary here.
I think to understand the
defense mechanism, we should
first define acting out.
Because we think of acting
out just hearing the words as
something that's volitionally done.
Right, but that's not
what we're talking about.
Defense mechanisms are unconscious, so
there's an automaticity to the response
that the person can see by reflection.
Because this isn't
conscious choice to act out.
That's something different.
That's bad behavior.
But what we're talking about here is the
thing that's automatic and unconscious
until we bring it into our conscious mind.
And acting out isn't
always dramatic either.
Here's one example.
So let's say in a relationship
situation, you have one person who
always does the dishes, other person
does something different, right?
That person does the dishes.
And it's onerous.
People have busy lives.
It's onerous.
Have to do a lot of dishes.
And every time things aren't
going so well, there's a little
bit of conflict between them.
The other person makes
twice as many dirty dishes.
This is exactly the kind of thing that
happens in relationship situations where
this little thing becomes a little crack
in the door that opens more, and then
there's a foot in the door, and now
there's a big problem because we act out
in these ways that we're not aware of.
So again, the person isn't
deciding, I'm going to do that.
So that person has to do more work,
but there's an automaticity to it.
And upon reflection, sometimes a person
could realize, I'm doing that, right?
Or it's a real example person who
realizes, I just make much more
difficulties around the house, I
make a lot more difficulties for my
partner and was like, whoa, this person
doesn't want to be doing that, right?
They love that person.
They don't want to be doing that.
But by realizing that when they can
bring a process of change and just
being more self aware and saying,
look, I don't want to do that, I don't
want that to be a defense anymore.
If I have conscious awareness
now, I can control it.
And maybe that person is
doing that other places.
Maybe the person says, you know, it
kind of goes that way at work too.
I could contribute to a project and
make something easier on a person.
And I realize I don't do that.
If I'm feeling in some negative
way, then we can go find, okay,
what might the roots of that be?
For example, did a parent
role model that behavior?
Was that done to them where the
parent was really good to them?
If they were behaving in the right way
and they make their breakfast, right?
And if not, well, you make it yourself,
or, oh, sorry, there's no milk.
These things happen.
And then the person gets in them.
Some array of circumstances, feelings,
responses, all the stuff that goes
on in the unconscious mind that then
throws up to the surface this kind
of acting out as a defense mechanism.
So I think it's important to
point out, and it's a good
example because it is unconscious.
And a lot of times how we're
doing it is not dramatic.
Andrew Huberman: What about salience,
this cupboard under the function
of self that I think we are all too
familiar with, what we pay attention
to internally and externally?
I have a sort of bizarre meditative
practice that I've talked
about before on the podcast.
I don't know why I came up with this,
but it's more of a perceptual exercise
that I do from time to time, where if I
feel like I'm too in my head, I literally
focus my visual attention outward.
I try and place on a horizon
or some object out there.
And other times, if I'm sort of in
the world too much and I want to get
back into myself, I'll close my eyes
and do a moment or two or more of more
traditional, what traditional means,
what people think of as meditation.
The practice involves setting aside
a minute or two and deliberately
stepping through closed eye meditation.
It's not really meditation again, it's
just recognize I'm a self, like here,
contained within the skin of my body.
Then I open my eyes, I look at my hand.
This all sounds very
silly as I describe it.
And then I think about a bridge.
Like my perception can be split between my
awareness of self internally and my hand.
Then I look out some distance, 10,
12 feet or so, and do the same.
I sort of bridge self awareness
with external awareness, and
I step out to the horizon.
And then I sometimes like
to do the exercise of...
It goes with a popular meme.
We're just like this pale blue dot I
think about myself right here, but then
the fact that I'm on a planet that's like
spinning in space and then right back
into myself, and then I go about my day.
And I developed that a few years
ago more on the basis of what I
know about visual perception and
interoception, our recognition of
inside versus exteroception, just
fancy language for recognition
and perception of what's outside.
But that's my practice of orienting
myself in life, because then I feel
like I have better buffers against
what happens around me and how
much I'm reacting or not reacting.
That's my practice.
I have a feeling it touches into a few
of these bins, but it certainly doesn't
get at approaching a specific problem or
thinking about where problems might exist
beneath the surface that I'm not aware of.
Paul Conti: Because it's only
one part of the equation.
It's paying attention to salience,
what you're doing then, you
are grounding yourself in order
to change salience, right?
And that is a strategy.
You said, oh, maybe it's
silly or this or that.
No, it's an understood and known strategy.
For example, variations of that are
what people can do to prevent panic
attacks, to change the salience.
If the salience is I'm going inside
of me and I'm feeling panicked and I
just have a feeling of awfulness, you
can change that salience by grounding
yourself to the world around you.
We tell people, place your hands
on the table, look at the specifics
of exactly what time it is.
Look at the shape of a doorknob.
Ground yourself so that
you can change salience.
Because now, as we move up the
hierarchy of function of self, we're
getting to using the conscious mind.
Things that are salient to us can be
external, they can be internal, and if
they're internal, they can be conscious,
and sometimes they're unconscious.
So it's not all about the conscious mind,
but we're bringing the conscious mind
to bear here to think about salience,
which combined with everything else, can
help us see what's under the surface.
Most of the time, what we're doing
is that act of self observation.
What is going on inside of me?
Which can be, what am I thinking?
This is how the person can
realize over and over, oh my
goodness, I'm saying to myself, X.
And for the first time they say out
loud and realize the thing they've
said to themselves 10,000 times.
Or it can be a feeling state.
Wow, what's salient to me is a feeling
state, say, of vulnerability, and
then everything seems threatening.
So salience, it's a form of self awareness
that we could say is using the conscious
mind now to tend to that garden of
self, to look at that garden of self
and say, what's really growing from it.
Is it all things I like?
It's going to be never all things
we like because it's a process.
But am I happy with it?
Am I not happy with it?
Are there weeds that are
coming up all over the place?
That could be the intrusive thoughts.
So we're using metaphors,
but it's actually very, very
concrete . The salience part is
what is going on inside of me?
And that's a very interesting
inquiry and informative.
Right.
It's interesting because it's informative.
Andrew Huberman: Do you think that's
an inquiry that's best done in
meditative like states or setting
aside some deliberate time to think
about what am I thinking about?
What am I paying attention to?
How am I allocating my thoughts
or my thoughts being allocated?
I guess we have to respect the
unconscious component here.
We don't just walk around saying,
I'm placed my attentional spotlight
there and then my thinking here.
Paul Conti: We always want to be
aware of what we, there are things we
don't know that's respectful, that's
appropriate humility, because it's true.
Andrew Huberman: So I'm assuming
this ratchets directly into the
cupboard of behavior, right?
What we're actually doing is that cupboard
best explored by listing off, perhaps
on paper, in our minds, what we're doing
each day is that one way to explore,
like, how am I spending my time again?
Not as an efficiency exercise, but
as a way to start to explore the self
and the mind for sake of building
up to more agency and gratitude.
Paul Conti: The routes to most
effective self inquiry, to bringing
the conscious mind to bear,
really differ widely by person.
There are some people who, they
are so well served by doing
that when they're meditating.
There are other people who they can really
get at that when they're playing a sport.
It's going on inside of them along with
the other things that they're doing.
Some people find it in the shower,
or they find it when they wake up
in the morning, or they find it when
they're with an animal they love.
Or they might find it when they're
reading a certain kind of material.
And then they read it, and then
the reading trails off and they're
thinking they're a reverie, sort
of inside so how we can engender
the best use of our conscious
minds is going to differ by person.
But again, we can think about that,
like, what really works for me.
Let me do more of that.
It's interesting.
We see people sometimes, I see people a
lot of the time who are, they're trying
to meditate to understand themselves.
And it's like not working right.
And it's like I must know how to
meditate in order to understand myself.
Well, it's not necessarily true.
It might be I must go on more hikes
in order to better understand myself
because that's how it works for me.
So that process of reflection can be
very, very helpful to us because we're
using our conscious mind to try and
either look inward, what is sailing
it to me, including understanding
that I don't understand everything,
but I can understand a lot of it.
And outward, what
behaviors am I engaging in?
What are my behavior patterns?
And to be reflective about that, to think
about that can be immensely helpful to us.
Like, how am I spending
those hours of the day?
What am I doing with my time?
Am I wasting my time?
Do I always get mad and say
something mean to somebody?
Why?
Because I had a negative
thought about something.
Am I doing that?
Have I kind of changed since something
unpleasant happened and now I'm not so
nice to someone in the household, right.
Or am I taking a lot better care
of myself since I started doing X?
Whatever.
X may be learning more about myself?
Right.
Doing more of the things I
like got left that old job.
It was so hard for me to leave.
I do actually get myself to the gym.
So it's a reflection upon self, because
a lot of what we do, we do automatically.
And that's very important.
The example that often is
given is, okay, think about how
you last brushed your teeth.
And the answer by like a blank.
Because you brush your teeth
in an automatic way, right.
Most of us don't remember that
because we just skip right over it.
So it makes sense.
It lets us think while we're doing things.
It lets a lot happen automatically
in the physical world, right.
Just as it happens inside
of us automatically.
But we can, there have sort of
too much of a good thing where too
much is happening automatically
and we want to stop and think.
And it's remarkable how sometimes
when people stop and think, they
might say, real example is, I don't
want to be spending five nights a
week at the bar and I'm spending
five nights a week at the bar.
Why?
Because I go home a certain way from
work, and there's a bar along that way.
And then I think, oh, I'll just
stop in and maybe see a friend.
And then I know that once I get in
there, I'm going to have a drink.
And I know once I have a drink, I'm going
to get three, and I'm going to have three.
And I see this pattern of behaviors
and how, like, I don't decide I'm
going to go to that bar instead of
going home to see my wife or my husband
or my kids or whatever it may be,
and I don't want to behave that way.
Because there, it's a great example of
how you can stop that from happening.
But once it starts happening,
the dominoes start falling.
It's very, very hard.
People don't generally realize, oh, my
goodness, I'm in the bar and I've had one
drink, and now I'm going to have two more.
That's not the time.
But the understanding, the reflection
upon behavior patterns can lead a
person to stop those behaviors, to
understand and recognize them, get
their arms around them, shine the
light of day on them, and then have
greater agency and greater gratitude.
I'm grateful I can go home to
my family, and that's what I
choose to do, and I can do that.
I do not have to end up at that bar,
and I'm not going to end up at that bar.
I'm going to drive a different way home.
And if I can't get myself to do that,
I'm have a friend in the car with me.
And if I can't do that,
I'll be in the backseat.
But I'm not doing that
thing I choose not to do.
And it's a more dramatic example and not
an uncommon one, but we can apply that the
whole way up the list, from nuances of our
behaviors down to more dramatic behaviors.
Andrew Huberman: I've heard you describe
the unconscious mind and some of its
other interconnected workings with the
analogy of a phantom in the driver's seat.
And we're in the backseat, of
course, all within one person, right.
This idea that we're just being taken
places that we don't want to go or
that we know we shouldn't go or that we
can't really figure out why we're going
there, and we have some idea, but we're
just not certain about what's going on.
It's not necessarily related to
really destructive action either.
I mean, it can be, but what you're
describing sounds to me a lot like
climbing out of the back seat and maybe
sitting in the passenger seat and looking
into the driver's seat and going, oh,
there's something else going on here.
Of course, all of this is one mind.
And in doing that, taking
some control of the vehicle.
Paul Conti: It's about
understanding what is that phantom?
Where did it come from?
That's how we get rid of it.
How do we get back in the driver's seat?
We don't grab the phantom and throw it
out the door or throw it in the backseat.
It's ephemeral.
We can't grab it.
So how does it go away?
It goes away through understanding.
So very common example that the phantom
in the driver's seat is trauma that we
have pushed in an unconscious place.
And now that whole under the
surface structure of the iceberg is
fragmented, and it's sort of roiling,
and there's a big problem there.
And if we go at that problem
and whatever, it's spinning
off, right, that's the abscess.
But it's a bad one.
And it's spinning off a lot of problems.
And that's why the phantom is in the
driver's seat, because healthy things
are not built on top of that fracturing
and roiling part of the iceberg.
We see that a lot.
The phantom could also
be something different.
It could be one defense mechanism
that's unhealthy that we are really
over relying on, and then we can
understand it through that lens.
So there are just a few examples.
But if we sort of wake up in the
backseat of the car, so to speak, and
the phantom is driving recklessly,
then how we get the phantom out of
the front seat is by understanding it.
And I always imagine, poof, it goes away.
Because now it's not
driving my life anymore.
I'm driving my life.
It's gone.
Andrew Huberman: The message that I'm
hearing over and over again in my head
is that no matter how well or how poorly
any of our lives happen to be going,
that by looking in these cupboards under
structure of self and function of self,
we can have so much more positive control.
Paul Conti: Yes.
That's why ultimately, what we're
talking about is optimistic.
We can't help ourselves
if we don't honor truth.
And the truth is that there
are complex aspects of this.
So, okay, we want to go look
at that, and we want to look
at how things can go wrong, and
that's all very, very important.
But that's all wrapped in the best
truth, which is that we can change it.
We can make it better.
That's why the self, the garden of self,
is on top of the structure of self.
And the top of the function
of self are our strivings.
That's what comes next after behaviors.
It's like, what are my behaviors doing?
What am I doing?
What am I striving towards?
What am I doing, literally?
Am I going to a job I hate?
Am I doing things I don't want to do?
Am I accepting treatment
that I don't want to accept?
Am I treating people in
ways I don't want to accept?
How can I strive for better?
And striving and hopefulness
are so intertwined.
So the pinnacle of the
function pillar is striving.
The pinnacle of the
structure pillar is self.
And we can see how the
self, the strivings.
What we're doing now is
combining the pillars.
It's where it comes together.
And your imagery of.
That's where the geyser comes from.
And we want that geyser to be healthy.
It's a stream of clear, clean
water that's coming out of it.
That's where our empowerment is.
But empowerment is a condition of being.
I am empowered.
Empowerment rests within me.
That's where humility
comes into the picture.
Humility also something within me.
I have humility.
They're not verbs, but empowerment
and humility then gain their
expression at the top of that geyser.
When agency and gratitude, those verbs,
arise from empowerment and humility.
Andrew Huberman: What you've drawn
for us is an incredibly compelling
picture, because the picture
or the map is really a roadmap.
It's a path to ideals.
And you've been talking about these
ideals of agency and gratitude across this
series, and they just encompass so much.
And as you mentioned before, they are
interconnected and they are verb states.
And a critical component of the
geysering up from the Pillars toward
agency and gratitude are these two
components of empowerment and humility.
Tell us a little bit more about
empowerment and humility and how
we should view empowerment and
humility in the context of self care.
Paul Conti: Well, empowerment is a state
that we can create for ourselves if
we're taking care of the pillars, right?
So we're looking in the cupboards.
We're doing the things that make
our map clearer and clearer.
This idea that, oh, that seemed like
a good path, but it gets clearer,
and there's a swamp there, right?
Or that didn't seem like a good
path because it's circuitous.
Oh, no.
But there are good things along that path.
So the map gets clearer as we
tend to the cupboards in the
pillars, and that empowers us.
We're in a state.
There's a state inside of us that
is a state of potentials that
are now skewed in a good way.
That's what empowerment is.
It's not something that happens.
It's a state that we then
bring to bear on what happens.
The same is true of humility.
Humility does not mean not acknowledging
things that are good about you.
And we often can very much
mischaracterize humility.
Like, is that person being weak?
Is it false humility?
Or people often who are
conscientious don't want to
acknowledge good things about them?
Oh, no, I'm not that smart.
That's not humility.
Humility is consistent with truth.
So if you keep saying you're not
that smart, but the world around you
tells you that you're that smart.
Then acknowledge that you're that smart.
That's coming through the lens of truth.
And we can go down to the pillars and
the cupboards and say, okay, how does a
person get to acknowledging that truth?
So it's only by squaring away
the things that humility isn't.
It is not denigrating ourselves.
And we see that in a lot of people.
I'm Humble.
And then that person often tells
you why they're accepting something
that's not good to accept.
So humility is about acknowledging
truthfully the characteristics that
you have within yourself, good and bad.
And here is where we can identify
things that we're not so happy with.
We have to have humility within us
in order to make ourselves better.
Just like I have to say, look, I'd
like to be more fit if I'm going to
then get myself in a more fit state.
So saying, look, I can be a little bit
snippy with people if I'm irritated, or
I can be a little bit condescending, or
I can be a little selfish at times, it's
hard to admit these things to ourselves.
But if we have the humility to
acknowledge those things, then
we also get to have that broader
humility about just being a person.
Like, wow, look how complicated
this is to navigate life.
I mean, these pillars are not simple.
And when we go down to the
real base elements of them,
it can get very complicated.
So then we have a compassion
for self and for others.
Sometimes I'll say to a person, I should
be doing this, I should be doing that.
They think they should be
doing something perfectly.
And I will say to them, it's amazing
that we're moving forward, right?
I mean, let's start with, wow,
it's not easy to be human.
It's not easy to navigate this world.
And that kind of humility can
then allow us to feel good about
what we build on top of it.
It's not easy to navigate this world.
And humans are pretty
vulnerable, by and large.
But I'm applying myself.
And I'm proud that I'm applying myself
or that I'm perseverant, but also I'd
like to be a little more compassionate.
It's that sort of thing that
combines with empowerment.
So empowerment and humility are
these potential states that then
express themselves or become
enacted however we wish to put that.
But they change into the active
verbs of agency and gratitude.
And agency and gratitude
are ways of being.
They're verbs.
They're active.
So that's the point of it.
From the sense of how we
are living.How we are being.
That's why agency and gratitude
is in some sense its own endpoint.
But because there's a circular
aspect of this, our active
being is not the endpoint.
If we're being in a healthy way,
then we get to experience things.
Peace, contentment, delight.
We experience them because we are healthy.
So we get to be through the
lens of agency and gratitude.
We get to experience peace,
contentment and delight.
And that makes a healthier us.
The drives and their expression
are in better balance.
The generative drive is
fostered and strengthened.
And the drives underneath of it,
the aggression assertion, proactive.
We're really using that in a good way.
And we're mining all of it within us.
Like, I want to bring that to bear,
and I can bring more of it to bear.
That's very, very good.
And the pleasure drive is active in us.
I'm enjoying the things I do.
I feel good about the things I do.
I'm making good choices.
And that state of health, what it
promotes, the pillars, the cupboards, to
stay clean and clear and healthy, right?
But life is life.
And the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune, the slings and arrows of
life will continue to come at us
and cause us to go back and look
at the pillars and the cupboards.
And even if they don't come at us,
those things are never perfect, right?
But that's not bad, because by tending
to them, where do we bring ourselves?
We bring ourselves back to the
active verbs of agency and gratitude,
the active verbs of living.
And here we are.
In this cycle that if we pay attention
to it, we use it to understand
ourselves, we use it to improve
ourselves, can bring us to better lives.
Andrew Huberman: How do you think about
a person, and I confess I've been this
person, perhaps still am to some extent,
who can really have a sense of agency and
gratitude in certain domains, maybe even
many domains of life, and yet feels as if
there are certain areas of life that are
just so much more challenging than others.
This stark contrast, like this
stuff works, can do that, but
this stuff is just really hard.
And maybe that continues long enough
that it almost starts to feel like, or
the person wonders whether or not maybe
that part of life is inaccessible to me.
It's just never going
to be successful for me.
How do you think about these carve outs of
functionality and lack of functionality?
That's probably not the right language,
but I think this is important because
it relates directly, I believe, to kind
of narratives that we tell ourselves.
I mean, they are narratives, right?
I think it's important to think about
these because they are intermeshed with
and perhaps even the consequence of
narratives that we have, like stories
about ourselves that we have internally.
And again, I'll be the first to admit that
I've felt this way for much of my life.
Certain things I can do,
other things far, far harder.
And sometimes it felt outside
the reach of possibility.
Paul Conti: I have a very
concise answer to this one.
In fact, it's nine words.
Don't make yourself special
in ways that hurt you.
And we tend to do that as humans.
Oh, I get to have A, B and
C, but I don't get to have D.
I get to have professional success.
And I'm in pretty good shape and
I have a lot of friends, but I
don't get to have a relationship.
I mean, over and over and
over, because the relationship
part is so emotionally laden.
It's the part that gets carved out, right?
Falsely carved out the most.
But it can happen in any arena
of life where we make ourselves
special in a way that really is
black magic or is being cursed.
You have the machinery, the ability,
the function to go about pursuing the
things you want and get them right.
That sounds like a pretty good
paradigm, except about something
really important to you.
That can't be.
We're applying the same machinery
of self because we're talking about
things people want in a broad scale.
Like, I would like professional success.
I would like personal success.
I would like to do well in my family
unit and be a good family member.
I would like romance.
So we're talking about areas of self.
And we will make ourselves special by
carving out one and then applying black
magic or some cursed state that then
takes that away from us and that creates
tremendous consternation that will throw
all of those cupboards in those pyramids
off balance because we don't like that.
That seems mysterious and ominous.
What is there that you don't
know that's about being cursed
so you can't have something.
And then that makes anger and
frustration in us and more likely that
we'll act out or we'll be frustrated
and we start enjoying things less.
Sometimes a person can wall something
off like that and they can go
forward with the rest of life.
I mean, it affects them,
but it's not obvious.
It's not on their mind all the time.
Which is why the process of self
inquiry can reveal important
things like, oh, I pretend that I
don't even care about professional
success, and why do I do that?
It's the only thing I'm not
doing very well because I
think it's impossible for me.
It's not something I get.
Why?
Because I got other things.
So I don't get that.
Okay, now we're really curious about that.
And sometimes it causes very, very big
problems where a person can build an
external sense of self that soothes
some of their vulnerability so they
can present in a certain way, but
underneath of that, they're hiding the
sadness or the pain of what is missing.
But that is then sort
of eating away at them.
And their feelings of self on
the inside don't match what
people see on the outside.
We see a lot of this.
And the process of self inquiry, of self
exploration, of curiosity about self
can lead us to realize what we've carved
out if we don't already realize it.
Or it can help us to see that
the carve out makes no sense.
It's as if you said, well, there
are nine roads around my home and
they're all just regular old roads.
I can drive on eight of
them, but not the 9th.
You said, well, it doesn't make
any sense if they're similar.
It requires the same set of skills, right?
If you know how to drive the car and
have the visual acuity, why wouldn't
you be able to drive down the 9th?
But even though that's a very mundane
example, but it's that, that we apply
to very important and emotionally
charged aspects of our life.
I get to have physical fitness
and friends and career success,
but I don't get to have love.
I mean, we hear people say this.
And that's a very powerful way
of taking us away from what
we want to achieve in life.
It takes us away from the active
agency and gratitude and all
the good that comes of that.
Andrew Huberman: What you just said makes
a lot of sense, especially the point that
if we have nine roads around us and we can
drive down eight of them, why not the 9th?
Because it places us back into the
verb tense and the action tense
of the car like we're a vehicle.
The eye that we can
take through the world.
Sure, conditions matter.
Maybe road number nine has boulders
on it, but it can't be that roads
one through eight were all just
smooth superhighways either, right?
Those had challenges and we.
I'm not going to use myself as example.
I, for whoever is doing this sort of
exercise, had a mind that was able to
work around those boulders, right, of
challenging people, of limited finances.
These are all things I've experienced.
And of course, people come into the world
with different levels of challenge and
privilege and accessibility, et cetera.
We don't want to deny all of that.
But those other eight roads are rarely,
if ever, perfectly smooth roads.
Paul Conti: That's why it's
completely about the self, right?
And it's the realization that if
I brought myself to bear and I got
down the first eight, I can bring
myself to bear and get down the 9th.
And as you're pointing out, it's not
like the first eight were easy, right?
Maybe one of them was
really pretty smooth, right?
But there's going to be a couple
of them in there that have raised
really strong difficulties, things
to surmount and to overcome.
And it's from that place of understanding
that we find within ourselves the courage,
the strength to go down the 9th road.
Even if we see greater
barriers, even if we're okay.
I'm aware now, but I'm also aware that
I avoided that 9th road for a reason.
The boulders and the potholes,
they're more severe on that road.
In fact, I'm kind of worried
that it's impassable.
But it can't be impassable, right?
If there's boulders there, I'll
go rent some excavating equipment
or I'll fill in the potholes.
And that's how we get ourselves to go
forward and to acknowledge and validate.
Like, I'm afraid of doing that.
If I weren't afraid of doing it, I
would have done it already, right?
But I now realize what the truth is and
what I brought to bear in the first eight.
And I'm going to bring
myself to bear for the knife.
That's also when we recruit often
resources around us where we might
say, let me tell a couple of good
friends about this, or a clergy member
or a therapist or a trusted other and
let me explore this more in myself.
And that's often how in making
ourselves better, we engage
more with the people around us.
And then the support from someone else
that may help a person do that, is
support given back to the other person.
And this is also how we
build the beyond self.
Is that the path to travel
down the 9th road, so to speak.
We don't have to travel alone much of
the time, but that often, almost always
wasn't in the person's mind, right.
They perceive it's a three
person job to go down.
It's like, great, you have two friends.
Andrew Huberman: Yes, certainly.
Where I've been able to travel down
certain roads, the key features have been
a desire to go down that road, recognition
of the landscape, but not trying to
take on the whole thing all at once.
And then finding really good
people and frankly, really trying
to avoid people that seemed
poisonous to the journey, right.
That were going to throw toxic
things into the engine of my vehicle
and that's putting a lot on them.
But it just felt as if going down those
other roads was too valuable an expedition
to spend time on and with people that
it wasn't helpful to spend time with.
And at the same time, there have
always been good people that have
presented themselves with examples.
I think this is where it comes to mind.
It's not always the case that
you got a friend who's saying
you can do this and here's why.
Or a therapist that says you
can do this and here's why.
But that there are examples in the world
of like, well, this person did this.
I think when we have challenges in a
certain domain, that 9th road, so to
speak, I know for myself that I know I'm
in a place of futility when I start to
reflexively orient towards others that
have had a problem getting down that road.
Like, oh, I recognize this other
person who's been good at roads
one through eight but not nine.
And it occurred to me during the
course of this series, really, that
why not pick different examples?
Paul Conti: So if you're going on a
journey and it's a really important
journey and it's a difficult
journey, but it can be awesome.
Bring good people.
Have them on your journey,
be on their journey.
And then you think, well, why would
a person not bring good people?
If I were going on a journey and it's
going to be arduous but wow, we could
see amazing things along the way.
I can bring a couple of people with me.
I don't want to choose a couple of people
who are lazy, some who don't look at the
world around them, and some that won't
be helpful to somebody else's needs.
Why would one choose that?
It comes back to the self, right?
If a person, now we're
talking about any journey.
Because it's the journey of life.
If a person is choosing
people, you wouldn't choose
to be on the journey with you.
It's because you don't think
that you're worth better.
And if you think that you're worth
better, you won't choose the people.
You'll say, I want other people like me.
I'm going to be diligent,
perceptive, collegial, cooperative.
So I'm going to surround
myself with people like that.
And if we look beyond ourselves at groups
of people and at culture, the healthier
we are, the more we ally with healthy
people and the more healthy we are.
Because we're making ourselves healthy,
we get healthier groups of people.
The journey is better for all of us,
and this is how we can make the whole
culture better .Potentially, this is how
we can make life on the planet better.
But it has to start somewhere.
So it has to start with the I.
Andrew Huberman: I love, love, love the
message that if you're heading off on
a journey that's really meaningful to
go with and make sure that you interact
with good people, this is actually a
place where a reference to social media
and online communities is actually
worthwhile and can be very beneficial.
I think it's easy for us to
kind of roll our eyes at self
help and things like that.
On the other hand, there are communities
online that I consider myself a part of,
but for which I and many other people
have derived a lot of strength, a lot
of reassurance and confidence, right?
Because a lot of people are isolated.
They might have access to one or two
people in their community that they
really value, but those people are
perhaps also busy with other people.
Or I can remember being a student
alone in my studio apartment as an
undergraduate, feeling very much against
the grain of my local environment.
Too much partying for me at the time,
meaning I wasn't partying and there
was a lot of partying around me.
And had I been a better student
in high school, I probably would
have been able to healthily engage
in that, but I just wasn't able.
So, feeling pre isolated,
but knowing I was on a path.
So in that case, it was one professor,
one graduate student, and a hell
of a lot of books and music that,
to me, just carried me through.
Nowadays, I'm fortunate to
have many more direct resources
in my life of amazing people.
But I just want to mention that because I
think in this discussion around self care
and the various practices, I think there
are sure to be people who are that kid,
that woman, that man that's alone in a
room thinking like, okay, but how, right?
I see the grocer once a week and I see my
neighbor, and they don't even say hello.
And how to start to access some
of these better connections.
Paul Conti: Navigating the online
world is navigating the world.
It comes down to understanding and choice.
So if we're understanding as best we
can, we're making choice as best we can,
then we'll find great things online.
They're great things to find online.
Same is true of life.
If we're searching for something that,
for example, allies us around hatred,
around acting out, around things that make
us unhappy, even around commiseration,
instead of thinking about how we can
make things better, then we bring
ourselves in a different direction.
That's life.
If we understand and we choose
as best we can, we will lead
ourself to better places.
Andrew Huberman: Such an important
message and is a perfect segue into a
question that I, and I'm certain many,
many other people have about anger.
And not just anger from
interpersonal conflict.
Like somebody said something and
it really upset me, but stuff that
we see, stuff that we observe in
the world, it could be acts against
other people, words against other
people, or that we take reference to.
And I think many people feel yanked around
by, even dragged by something they see
and they can't get it out of their head.
Now, there could be all sorts of
reasons related to each and all of us,
why we can't get it out of our head,
work that we need to do, et cetera.
But according to the map of mental health
that you've laid out for us, things
that get in the way of that generative
drive are really quite poisonous to
our well being and the well being of
the world, because that generative
drive is about learning, creation, and
tends to be pro social in so many ways.
Tell us about anger and how from a frame
of reference, of trying to engage in self
care, we should think about our anger
and work with our anger in ways that can
perhaps even help us and not harm us.
Paul Conti: In order to really
understand this, and this is so
important, we have to define three words.
And the word to start with is affect.
So affect is aroused in us, meaning
we don't have control over it.
So anger is an affect.
It is aroused in us.
The idea being that if a person is
walking down the street and someone
jumps in front of them and shoves
them, anger is aroused in them.
They don't choose to be angry.
In fact, the body reacts and has all sorts
of fight or flight responses before the
person even realizes that they're angry.
So we can't control what is aroused
in us in the immediate term.
We can.
In the longer term.
If I have a short fuse and I get
angry really easily, I can't really
control that in the next ten minutes.
Meaning the affect that's aroused in
me, I can do different things with it,
but I can't change what's created in me.
But if I'm living a better life,
taking better care of myself, the
generative drive is better expressed.
I have more pleasure in my life.
Then what happens is the
mechanisms that arouse so much
anger start to arouse less anger.
So by taking care of ourselves, we arouse
less anger, but anger is aroused in us.
Okay, the next word is feeling.
Right again, there are different
definitions for these words, but the way
we're defining them, affect is aroused.
Feeling is when we take that affect
and we relate it to the self, it's the
next thing that happens on the way up.
Because the arousal of affect
is very deep in the brain as it
comes up, the next thing it does
is relate that affect to self.
So this is where the classic
example of a person who spills
something, they are angry.
That thing is spilled,
it raises anger in them.
Then they become aware, and
they match the anger to self
and say, what a dummy, right?
What a jerk.
I'll never do anything, right.
They say it inside, right?
Because the anger gets
enacted against the self.
Now, how would we like that to
go where the person is taking
better care of themselves?
So when they spill something,
less anger is aroused.
And by the time it gets to
consciousness, there's less anger,
so it's easier to manage, and
there's a stronger sense of self.
All the other aspects of the pillars
and the cupboards are in a good place.
Then the person is better able to
manage what anger makes it to feeling
and then to say, okay, everybody
spills something now and then, or
whatever, and then to clean it up.
And the person doesn't have to
enact the anger towards themselves.
So affect feeling and then emotion.
So emotion is when we relate
the affect and the feeling to
others in the world around us.
So, for example, a person might spill
something and then it arouses anger, and
now they get to the feeling part, but
they have a set of unhealthy defenses,
and they don't think they're responsible
for things they're responsible for.
So they just keep that load of
anger, right, that affect upwards
until they get to emotion.
And then they decide, that
wasn't my fault, it was yours.
And that's why maybe they kick the
dog or they slap somebody or they say
something mean like, this happens.
So if it happens a lot, like this is
part and parcel of what's going on in us.
A lot about negative emotions.
There can be dramatic examples, but
there's smaller examples that are
winding their way through our lives.
And the better we take care of ourselves,
the less aroused negative affect we
have and the better we cope with it.
When it gets to the level of the I and
when it gets to the level of the you.
And if we think about prosocial
collaborative behaviors versus the
inaction of anger on a large scale, if
by the time it gets to you there's still
a lot of anger there, it is very easy
to then paint with a broad brush, right?
Oh, the problems are that
demographic, the problems are
those people who aren't like me.
That's where anger is
at its most dangerous.
So the idea of having the negative affect
under control, having the understanding
and the control mechanisms, keeps us from
getting to that broader level, the level
of you, and then working in ways that
are not pro social but are antisocial.
And this, I think, also relates
to what we can find online.
We can find online everything
we can find in the world.
So then we have a choice.
Are we going to work on understanding
what choices are we going to make
about how we're engaging in the world?
And if we're choosing the good things,
we're taking better care of ourselves
and we're better sort of citizens
of our relationships, of our family
units, and ultimately of our societies.
Andrew Huberman: I've observed
anger directed my way.
Certainly I'm far, far from perfect.
I have thousands of flaws, and
I've directed anger towards others
in ways that I wish I hadn't.
A common observance I've had about
myself and others is that when angry,
a lot of valuable time is wasted.
Instead of placing my efforts within
the generative drive, creating
things that I really value, the
anger becomes an immense distraction.
And I've seen this a lot, not just on
university campuses, but one place I
have seen it is when I was a graduate
student or postdoc, there would be
some interaction either between them
in the laboratory I was in, although
rarely, but more often it was about
some interaction between a student or
postdoc and someone in the outside world.
And so they'd come in and
they'd be really upset about it.
And there's a tendency to try and support
one another, which I think is healthy.
But then it was like this would just
continue and continue, and the person
would be sitting in their chair.
It was really upsetting.
And sometimes these were really upsetting
occurrences that warranted taking
some time and just really stopping.
But often I felt like things just kept
spiraling up and spiraling up, and it's
like halfway through the day, and again,
I'm not immune from this, but I observed
it more than I felt it, certainly.
It's like, wow, that's a
lot of time wasted, days, or
perhaps even weeks and months.
And then there's the sleep
loss that goes with anger.
I think that's one of the things about
social media and online communities
that's new and unique, is that it used
to be when kids went home from school
or we go home from work, something
might have happened there, but you
didn't have access to more incoming.
People weren't calling you on the phone,
telling you things that you don't like
or talking about others in ways that
you don't like, whereas all you have
to do now is pick up social media.
And if you're not really deliberate
in how you interact with social media
and on the internet and which news
articles you read and which ones you
scroll past, that can be accessible
at two in the morning when you're up
about t he thing that was angering you
during the day, that is new, right?
And requires elevated levels of diligence.
Paul Conti: Right.
High levels of anger bring volatility
and confusion, and that doesn't
serve anyone or anything well.
Lower levels of anger can be healthy.
I'm angry at that, and I want to
try and make it right, or I'm angry
at that, and I'm going to have my
say in it, or I'm going to have my
vote in it or whatever it may be.
Lower levels of anger are okay.
They can inform us, they
can guide our behaviors.
But when we get to high levels of
anger, it's volatility and confusion.
The person ceases to then be effective.
And here's an example.
When you were telling me about how you
feel when you're doing the solo podcast.
And how your agency and your gratitude
are really in action, and you're feeling
the peace and you're delighted, and the
generative drive is at the fore in you.
And then I had said, what if we
add a little bit of anger, even,
right, to kind of make the, And
then your response was like, oh,
it would all come offline, right?
Because there you're doing something
that calls for, like, you to really be
at your best, firing on all cylinders.
So even a little bit of anger is too much.
But it's a good example because
it shows, like, you're able to do
this thing that is so good for you.
You're living in the place.
If you could have all of existence be
like you feel, then you would love it.
You could bring it to all
the rest of your life.
Like, that's the nirvana we're going
for, and you're actively living it,
but we could throw it off and ruin it
with even a little bit of anger, right?
So it's an example that models for us
how higher levels of anger cause problems
in situations that are not so rarefied
as that high levels of anger, maybe
somebody blurting out somebody attacking
somebody, somebody saying something they
shouldn't, somebody making a bad decision.
Anger isn't good for us at high
levels, and we can decrease it
by making ourselves healthier.
Then we make less of it and we
control it better, and we keep
ourselves at the low to moderate
levels of anger, hopefully low.
Again, no, anger is not good.
High anger is not good.
Let's try and live in the low range.
Occasionally, something is very
distressing, we rise up to moderate.
That's where we have
anger in a healthy place.
Andrew Huberman: When we set out on
this journey to explore what is mental
health, I had no expectation that you
would deliver to us this incredible map
of how to explore our inner territory
and that you would spell out such
crisp and clear ideals of states and
ways of being and things to access.
Nor did I know anything about the
generative drive and the other
drives that reside within us.
In thinking about self care and in
thinking about the sorts of things
that people are challenged with
often I made out a little list.
Not just anger, but things like
scared, embarrassed, grieving,
dejected, tired, confused, stuck.
And then I wrote, infinite
number of these, right?
I mean, there have to be an infinite
number of challenges that people face,
an infinite number of circumstances,
and perhaps even an infinite combination
of those things that people face
and circumstances that can make it
all seem like a giant oppressive
cloud within us and around us.
And yet, what you've provided is really a
path of clarity, because it's a path that
certainly includes a lot of complexity
down in those pillars at the bottom,
the structure of self, function of self.
But you've directed us toward looking
into that complexity, looking into
those cupboards, as a way to arrive
at answers that bring us toward more
simplicity, empowerment, humility, agency,
gratitude, peace, contentment, delight.
And this incredibly attractive thing,
the generative drive that is really
accessible to any and all of us.
Paul Conti: It's there in every one of us.
Andrew Huberman: In providing
this path of clarity.
And again, I want to remind people that
whether or not you feel you're doing
well in life, maybe even in all domains
of life, or whether or not you're
experiencing challenge in any or perhaps
even all domains of life, going into those
cupboards is clearly of immense value.
And you've so graciously spelled out how
we can do that regardless of resources.
Really, it sounds like all it requires is
a desire to be better and feel better and
do better, and a willingness to explore.
Paul Conti: Curiosity, right?
If I had to summarize the whole thing in
two words, I would say be curious, right?
Because curious opens
the door to all of it.
Curiosity about self, curiosity about
life, leads to all the good things.
Andrew Huberman: Well, what you've
given us is of immense value, and
it's something that I know that I and
many, many other people are going to
take on as a positive set of goals,
not just for immense challenges, but
really for always right, for living
forward and understanding the past.
Never before have I been presented with
something that felt like it had as much
power and potency to do good as this.
Paul Conti: That's great.
I'm happy to hear that.
Andrew Huberman: Well,
it's absolutely true.
And I really want to thank you on
behalf of myself and everybody else,
for sharing with us your time, your
intellect, your willingness to build this
structure specifically for this series.
And for lack of a better
word, it's so generative.
Paul Conti: Thank you.
Andrew Huberman: And I'm sure that
people will have tons of questions
and tons of experiences of their
own to share in terms of using this,
and they can share that with us.
And that's one of the wonderful things
about podcasts, is they can put those
to the comments on YouTube or elsewhere.
Really, the comments on YouTube
would be the place to share those
questions and comments and feedback.
And perhaps going forward, we
can explore the self, the psyche,
relationships and ways to improve
all of that and our lives going.
Paul Conti: Yes, yes, this has been great.
It's been invigorating and
fun and thank you so much.
Andrew Huberman: Thank you for
joining me for today's discussion
all about true self care with Dr.
Paul Conti.
This marks the ending of the fourth
episode in our four episode series,
all about mental health with Dr.
Conti.
You can access each of the episodes
by going to hubermanlab.com, where
it's linked out to all formats.
And regardless of whether or not
you have now completed or you are
still in the process of digesting
the material from this series, I hope
you found it to be as enriching and
as useful in your life as I have.
And on behalf of myself and Dr.
Conti, I want to thank you again
for your time and attention.
If you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast, please
subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify and Apple.
You can leave us up to a five star review.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
Huberman Lab podcast, please put those
in the comments section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments, and if
you're not already following me on social
media, I am hubermanlab on all platforms.
So that's Instagram, Twitter,
LinkedIn Threads, and Facebook.
And on all those platforms I discuss
science and science related tools,
some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast, but
much of which is distinct from the
content of the Huberman Lab podcast.
So again, it's Huberman Lab
on all social media channels.
Not on today's episode, but on many
previous episodes of the Huberman
Lab podcast, we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't necessary
for everybody, many people derive
tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep, for
hormone support, and for focus.
If you'd like to see the supplements
discussed on the Huberman Lab Podcast, you
can go to livemomentous, spelled O-U-S.
So it's livemomentus.com/huberman.
If you haven't already subscribed to our
newsletter, it is a zero cost newsletter
called the Neural Network newsletter.
And in the Neural Network
newsletter you get free podcast
summaries as well as toolkits.
The toolkits are brief PDFs that
list off the specific science backed
protocols for things like improving
your sleep, improving focus, optimizing
dopamine, deliberate cold exposure.
We have a complete summary of
our fitness series, again, all
available completely zero cost you.
Simply go to hubermanlab.com, go to
the menu, scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email to sign up.
We do not share your email with anybody.
Thank you for joining me and Dr.
Paul Conti for today's episode.
And last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[Music Playing]